[Music]
all right hey hey folks here we are
we're here we're queer it's a beautiful
43° day in New York City when we're
taping I don't know what the actual
Christmas is going to look like oh good
point well could we could be dead by
then climate chain World War II yeah
Palestinians uh what else you got out
there speaking of explosions I just
dropped a Negron poop the likes of which
hey that's you yeah that's you I believe
it's a gingerbread man or boy thanks for
coming in Bud hey hey take your time hey
how are you you
again good to see you good to see you
who are you with Sloth sloth sloth yeah
drank with us I did oh yeah a problem
he's got a problem so while Ralph's
putting on his uh inmate outfit let's
hear about the uh the night of too many
stars oh I did a spot last minute
someone dropped out obviously when you
hear this lineup you're like yeah
someone dropped out John Stewart John
Stewart host okay uh John Oliver Chris
Rock wow uh Adam Sandler wow Robert
Smigel puts it together too many stars
uh with the jacket with the jacket I
like it he's a gingerbread guy but he's
like off the clock nice to meet you I
don't think we've met in person right
nice to meet you nice to meet you oh wow
I didn't know that worlds are colliding
so I did this thing on Monday night at
too many stars the benefit show it used
to be on TV yeah I remember that but
it's like for autism and uh I did one
joke I shouldn't have done too
but I uh it's like I walk in I'm like
holy that's Harvey kitel whoa It's
like people that you're like the is
that guy doing here was he autistic no
no no no but he could play autistic
think he's good and uh I want to
appreciate the money you made for my
people but then we we uh I go up and
it's like you know oh you know gaffan
everyone's there whatever I I get off
stage and it's like I did a couple jokes
I shouldn't have done I you know you go
into a joke I have a joke where the
punchline is uh special ed or
something I could have cut that one
probably right and uh and I get off and
the first face I see is kitel and he's
like GH and I like Harvey kitel
hates me and then I it's Steve Bui and
he's just like I could have just been
his face but uh that's like his face is
always like that you know and then I
funny looking and then I turn and it's
uh and Paul rod goes yes bailed out by
rud so many stars yeah Paul Rod's a
funny dude I love funny yeah Steve buam
is a little funnier but whatever that's
my comedy opinion yeah Steve Bushi rules
yeah oh big daddy he's the uh the hobo
yeah yeah sausage
McMuffin exactly even when he's not
funny he's funny yeah remember when he
got shot in the face on Sopranos was
hilarious I thought going to say Fargo
he's been shot in the face a lot yeah I
I never saw Fargo Fargo is good
I just remember he's got the the
groceries and he's like with the keys
and he's just like blam yeah pull that
up I use this to get
hard so oh this is Jamie by the way she
made us
drinks we're having Kito familiar with
it this is your
second thank you so much this my first
coito no oh yeah what's your background
though thank you um
Mexican yeah Puerto Rican it's not it's
not everywhere I guess kito's like a
Puerto Rican thing yeah oh yeah look
better uh eggnog I think oh wow had
eggnog either what does Kito mean little
coconut that's what it means but it's
different from egn where it doesn't yeah
this is so good damn and I usually hate
coconut yeah it does have eggs and it
has sweetened condensed milk where
eggnog has heavy like regular milk sugar
you just pull up with the dad get shot
in Fargo that was the wrong scene no
right this where sh oh yeah he shoots oh
yeah pull back a second right before he
gets shot it's the weirdest reaction of
getting shot J he just like o
he's like
[Music]
[Laughter]
oo like that would have been a good
Pepto commercial
like oh
shot in the face and improved
it wow what a mve Cohen Brothers yeah
you check out Fargo that's a good one
they put him in a wood chipper in the
end yeah now I'm still going to
watch it you can ruin endings for me
I'll still watch them same what are you
do you live in Texas no yeah kind of
wait for it oh with a
shotgun o oh wow on the firewood did you
guys ever watch Barry yeah that that was
a cool that's cool how he died yeah he's
like what he's like what did he say
what's his last line he's like oh wow
bam pull it up I didn't see the ending
of the show so it's the last season I'm
guess I'm sorry that's all right
watch this is such a spoiler load of a
podcast that's what's considered a great
show Bill hater is amazing but it's
funny that that's like a comedy yeah
like there a comedy try watching that
before bed on the road you're going to
want to Slit your wrist it's
show incredible I mean the acting is
insane Henry Winkler is like oh I love
Winkler by the way this is the
difference between men and women right
here there's no group of women sitting
around going pull up when Bushi gets
shot in the face on a
porch who's whose desktop cover is that
oh it's me is you is that from Dog Day
Afternoon you got it yeah that's bad
that's badass Christmas edition I put
the package in there nice that make a
good Halloween costume M yeah the suit
is tough though cuz they're like what
are you doing like you don't yeah nobody
would know no except like big alucino
fans right I don't know yeah just look
like a dead maybe gay guys that movie is
like a gay rights movie right trans
trans oh gay too kind of right yeah
in the way yeah it's all part of the
LGBT plus Q minus Jean this is Barry so
now I'm going to Know How It
Ends there we
go oh we're really going to spoil it for
this guy it what season are you on
I'm I'm one behind but I I'll still
watch it oh it was still an interesting
season yeah all right there you
go this is like the finale sorry guys
wait where's
Bushi I don't think he's in this oh oh I
thought that's what we were doing are we
not doing it I don't know Ralph just
brought it up it's about it's about to
happen Okay this is the long I don't
even remember this there's that mem
there's that Meme I forgot who did it
but it's like uh dudes can just sit
around and talk about like they can just
name role players in the NBA
that's what this is but like dude's
getting shot in the face right what if I
just got the movie
Wrong oh there you
go whoa Ron
[Laughter]
White oh wow oh that's fun all right all
right all right I'll still watch it I
feel bad for people you know died but
that's got to be a cool way to die like
getting shot yeah yeah people respect
you aom Al for that you know Teddy Teddy
Roosevelt was shot and I think it helped
him win the uh the
presidency he got shot during a speech
and then kept going why' he keep going
he was that tough speech was folded up
in his pocket so many times the bullet
pierced the speech just got the bullet
just got in him he finished the speech
and then went to the hospital there you
go you know whose president uh
presidency it didn't help was JFK that's
true didn't help his presidency yeah
they told him you should wear your
speech on your forehead and he didn't
listen
[Laughter]
who had that bit that Biden is the only
President you could punch assassinate
Shan oh that's funny that is
hilarious you
punch anyway yeah I I live in Texas but
I've been coming to live here every
other week for a little while like for
for a month maybe damn yeah might as
well get a condo or something yeah
that'd be cool I mean I stay at my
friend's place in Queens I just going on
the rent with him so I got like a like
an apartment now I guess but I do want
my own place cuz I don't I don't know
all my stuff's like some in his room and
some in his living room but I don't know
I'm never home anyway you know that's
how I feel sometimes right we never I I
looked I went in my living room just my
you know other room I have two rooms and
it's just two giant suitcases open same
my apartment always is you know yeah
people are like you should clean your
room I'm like I'll be there for a few
hours need to pick some out maybe
do some laundry and I'm out that's it I
feel good like sleeping in transit me
too yeah we're on that tour bus that was
the best sleep I got in a long time oh
man isn't that sad I feel the same way I
did a bus this year and I was like I I
sleep like at home yeah I know the
bus is where I was meant to be even I
even sleep better on a plane than I do
at home like all like stiff and stuff
right but I don't know somebody recorded
me sleeping at the airport that wasn't
cool oh yeah I like sat on they tagged
you yeah they tagged me I was like what
a that's pretty funny damn whoever
it is I punch them well they're no I
won't they're a woman but I get my mom
to punch them that was up it's
probably better it's a woman a dude is
would be worse I think oh I've been
tagged by dudes recording me sleep is
that sleep a lot yeah well I usually
sleep at the airport maybe you're
narcoleptic no no no I can't sleep like
at night but once I'm at the airport and
I'm like 15 minutes till we board then
I'm just like all right all right I'm
the same way the body knows it like
starts to go into shutdown mode and then
there's a delay a 15-minute delay and
you're just like that you threw
everything off now I'm for the day
it's all it's all hinging on that it's
got to be an on time departure 6:00 a.m.
flight that's why mostly Fly Southwest
they're the most consistent but I don't
know one time well a few times I flew
Delta and I liked having like Comfort
Plus or even like first class but
there's been two Delta flights that get
delayed and I'm just like nah I can't
risk it right can't risk do you fly in
day of yeah I'll fly in day of same yeah
the you you do a day early sometimes
only the only way I'll do a day early
he's a nerd the only way I'll do it is
if it's two theater shows in a night
okay if it's one show I'll risk it but
if it's two I'm like I'm myself
all right all right all right if it's a
club I always go day of yeah I haven't
done theaters yet so I'm yeah I take
back the nerd thing yeah the next year
January yeah yeah yeah man I first saw
you on I think the first bit I saw of
you I forgot even the song it was but
you're like it was a rapper who bragged
about going speed limit oh quo that's
that's a great bit yeah he won't
open my
DMs but yeah no thank you I like that I
like that one that one got me some
followers but I am like damn I can't
really do that on the road now right
people know it yeah sometimes people
will yell at like do that one I'm like
nah that's weird no but that's nice
though that he's getting requests it's
flattering but you're like but you heard
it funny when it's a like it depends on
the comics I remember like many years
ago I'm opening for Gary Gman and people
were like
grapes it's just funny the bits it like
you know you could tell the type of
comic you are yeah Gaffin said there's a
a guy who follows him all to all his
gigs and dresses as a Hot Pocket and
he's outside dancing and like damn that
is the height of a yeah but he goes all
his gigs I don't know I feel like that'd
be pretty funny like all the time just
never acknowledge the guy though how
long he does it for yeah cuz it doesn't
ruin the ACT he just outside it's funny
the first time and like the 19th time
every other time right right this guy
the first time and in that time where
you're like you're still doing this oh
yeah I like that yeah man so what is
like you've been on you've been out with
like berth this year and you've been on
the road like this year you've been
really going hard right yeah yeah I
guess so it's been all right you know
you get lots of free stuff which is cool
yeah this is how fast his Rises this guy
hosted for me 10 minutes ago and then
now Netflix I got an agent after that
they're like you hosted for Mark
Norman was Harvey W want to get you on
the road yeah
yeah that yeah I hosted for you at uh
was it Arlington improv that was it yeah
Arlington improv is cool they got like
an arcade in there yeah and which one is
the Arlington improv in the middle of
Texas oh oh right yeah they got they got
an arcade in the bar and I mean Comics
gets to play for free like all the games
are free it's like one of those like you
pay 10 bucks and then you get to go play
or whatever and so it was cool opening
for people there cuz you get to just
like kill time in the arcade right but
now I can't go in the arcade anymore
like somebody will stop my game right
yeah what's your what's your game well I
like playing like Marvel versus Capcom 2
they also got uh they got Mortal Kombat
in there but I don't know if I just suck
at Mortal Kombat 2 or if they got that
one on hard that's it's a
yeah you're play and then like the other
character cuz every Mortal Kombat
character has like the same melee
attacks and they do the like the
straight punches but like non-stop
you're just
like I know you can't
compete with that but if I get raid and
I got a pretty good chance cuz I'll do
the lightning tackle you know he goes
what oh yeah he's got the stick right
Raiden N I don't think so does he he's
got the weird hat he's got the Hat he's
the Chinese weird hat he a cool ass hat
man yeah yeah yeah you I don't know if
it's racist to wear that hat but I'm
going to buy that hat oh those are great
it's oh my God remember thaty there was
a bar and the guy wore that hat outside
yeah and and the whole the whole thing
about the bar was five shots of anything
10 bucks oh which downtown New York
pretty good very good but like I do you
think they water that down oh yeah
and I think people died in there sound
like a nightmare yeah I think it's gone
now right you're not getting a good
customer base with that deal not with
that hat yeah do you guys get recognized
at bars and then it causes you to get
super drunk cuz then they give you free
drinks and stuff yes yeah and I can't
say no cuz you know you grew up broke so
then somebody's like here's a shot at
tequila I'm like well I have to take
this this is $12 yeah when I was when I
was eight I could have never
imagined yeah getting getting drunk is I
didn't used to drink a whole lot like I
was I was like I'd be like no I'm okay
you know but welcome to the P yeah man
you have a bit about though how it makes
how alcohol tastes better if it's child
father yeah yeah I don't know I think uh
this has been like an emotional year
like I've never been in my emotions this
much and that's what caused me to drink
more yeah don't do that
sorry usually touches your leg so you
got to
flucky yeah this is good at like hiding
feelings oh yeah and and it just turns
them into happiness here here well if
you have the right type of if you're the
right type of drinker some people
H they go angry they go Angry I've seen
no I've seen that what I I'll be honest
when I black out I go Angry really
really yeah I mean I haven't been there
I mean you know you get a bad report the
next day yeah somebody told me that I
blacked out and then I and then I opened
up a 12pack of sodas and I just started
smashing them on the ground which I
think was still pretty cool but they
said I was just like cussing a lot all
right yeah that's not so bad I thought
you were hitting a woman or something
nah nah that's later love I'm a love not
a fighter yeah no you're fine there's a
lot worse drunks yeah I'll be all right
yeah you should see my dad he bad drunk
oh my God I met him he's so nice where'd
you meet my dad uh New Orleans right
right yeah he was sober okay you give
him a few pops and it is just black ey
City mom that it's it's those it's those
really nice quiet dudes they got all the
anger pent up exactly exactly comedians
yes yeah it's Cosby did he hit you ever
oh man he would always hit me on the ass
but he would hit you know he would hit
you pretty good did you have a nice ass
I I used to yeah beat the out of it
he SP it out of
you uh one time he was tying my shoes
and I kept moving my foot you know oh I
hate when my son does that I was a dick
I was a piece of kid and uh he just
he gave me the uh the shake and then the
spin and then the
wallup the
trifecta I don't know why I'm imag
Imaging you your dad hitting you but
like in a in a silly
play no no play and then when you turn
you around they do the sound
effect no no it was bad and he would
always be like what are you gonna do if
you go in the military huh somebody GNA
put your shoes on for you I was like
Jesus Christ have you met me I'm not
joining the
military I'm I'm not going to be General
Norman yeah parents have the weirdest
questions man oh yeah like the weirdest
wh ifs my my friends brother-in-law's
dad died my friend has six sisters wow
and one of their husband's dad who lives
in Mexico died and my friend's mom was
telling him in front of me she's like
did you tell did you tell Javi like that
you're sorry his dad died or whatever
and my friend doesn't like talk to this
guy much yeah like they don't they said
they've said two words to each other in
the last eight years he's like no I
haven't seen them and she's like what's
the matter with you haime she's like one
day what what when your dad dies who's
going to comfort you he was just like I
don't know I you like I think not Javi
the my sister's husband who I talked to
twice like right well you're a dad yeah
I'm a dad so are you asking weird
questions yeah I guess so I like
sometimes he walks slow I'm like what
are you going to do if if you're around
fast
walkers but he's just like not go around
fast Walkers and I'm like he's a smart
kid yeah got me there yeah he's four
he's he's he's all right he's doing
better than I am at that age you were a
kid Young yeah I had a kid when I was 22
whoa yeah yeah it's crazy I you know
it's a good thing that I didn't have any
success at 22 I would have had more kids
cuz I can't have kids now yeah well
according to doctors you
know shoot blanks yeah apparently oh
really yeah I went and got a Sean
analysis just for the hell of it maybe
it's not your kid n yeah he is oh okay
to just for trying to go Columbo on his
ass just for cool Point here I took I
took ownership of him when I still
wasn't sure if he was my kid damn but
then we got a DNA test they're like nah
he is your kid and I was like oh
let's too bad you weren't like a a big
comit that could have been a live stream
you could have made some bank on
that I don't know but if I would have
been getting more like attention from
girls back then I would have had more
kids which probably yeah probably not
would have been a good it probably
wouldn't have been good you know oh yeah
yeah but I went and did a Cen analysis
one time just cuz I I just I don't know
I was curious about that stuff really
yeah and there was a you could take a
Sean analysis for like 125 bucks at a
clinic and I thought that was kind of
cool I always wanted to like medically
masturbate oh yeah they give you a room
and some porn right yeah Sean analysis
sounds like a Michael Douglas movie from
the St Michael Douglas and Demi Moore
I'm too scared to get the results
they're going to be like oh your jizz is
fine but you have
AIDS I thought I don't know I just I
just thought it would be like a fun
experience I don't know why I thought it
would be funny to jack off in a doctor's
office yeah and like I went to the
office like I got a ride there I got
dropped off like if I was going to the
movies or some and uh I did it like
I was in the did they give you a
magazine or something yeah so they put
you in this room with like a magazine
but I mean you got your phone they give
you the code to the Wi-Fi too okay but
the magazine got me started a magazine
the mag and the magazines were from like
the9
that was pretty hot yeah damn no asses
they they they had no Playboys they had
like dirtier stuff than playboys and
under 18 what the hell is this that's
crazy um yeah and then like I thought I
was like man once I got to the doctor I
was just kind of like man why do I do
this like this going to be kind of weird
like what if I can't even like get one
out I was actually it actually was way
quicker than at home like the whole
thing it was like a hot experience I was
like this is cool like yeah cuz
it's kind of wrong yeah and then you're
like oh if I jerk off this quickly in
public not public but in in a new like I
could jerk off other place totally the
thing yeah the whole thing was like fun
I don't know but yeah I gave him the cup
and I had to walk by like the desk with
the receptionist ladies and I don't know
it f at first it kind of felt weird even
that felt like a flex like check this
out
like I had no problem it's a
coito that's what they call these in
Puerto Rico that's a small nut put a
little put a little garnish in it yeah
then I went back to like the waiting
room and they called me back and the
doctor was like look there's like four
criteria that your Seaman has to meet
for you to be able to have
kids and why is it on your
lips the guy was like yours yours meets
none of them I was like wait what and he
like yeah like or I met three of them I
think at a four it was like like my
sperm is not sh AP right just like very
low count like very few of it is even
moving whoa yeah and uh something El I
forgot what it was they were like I was
like wait so can I not have kids and
he's like I'm not going to say you can't
have kids I will say that there's a very
very like small small chance like close
to none he's like but you know if you
want to have kids we can refer to you
refer you to a specialist and you get
started on that stuff he's like but we
recommend you do that sooner than later
they're like within a few years you'll
have no chance of having kids or even
like fixing it wow like holy I was
like this day started off so funny it's
not funny anymore yeah and you just jizz
too like what a weird shift went from
like hey all right to damn that sucks
but I mean it was whatever it's not like
I was like like yeah I'm going have kids
one day and like a family anyway so I
like it's whatever yeah but maybe I
wonder if something in you new like I
need to go get that cuz I've never had
an urge to get my jizz check Primal
level yeah I I think there was like uh
no I mean like to even have a kid
earlier is what I meant oh oh oh
interesting yeah I think there was like
a few scares that turned to nothing that
maybe had like G given me an idea like
what if I just can't have kids you know
but I don't know going to that clinic
was
like I don't know I'm glad that I found
out because
look for being honest I wasn't going to
be pulling out anyway yeah that's true
you know now I'm just more comfortable
with it
right I don't know sometimes the fear of
giving somebody a baby that's the
hottest part yeah good point good point
like this could ruin my life this
is so hot or hers you know or
hers that's true that is hot yeah it's
pretty hot yeah ruining lives that's
just hot all around just the idea but
you don't actually do it yeah the idea
once you ruin it it's not hot no more no
no then then you got to kill her the
risk no but that's fun maybe I'll get my
G checked I you know you want a jiz and
stuff do we'll do an episode oh patreon
I gave you my doctor's card please
doctor now we're doing it
here nice turn around we might be
infertile they should make like a CVS
test and maybe we could just put the
strip in the just wait five minutes
it's like Co yeah like I got two
lines dude the hard part to be for me
would be not to call it every other like
jizz come you know spunk you gota say
Seaman I never heard the spunk that's a
good word I'm gonna steal
that a good one J is classic what
else is there splooge splooge baby
batter nut I like nut nut is good yeah
nuts make the world go around oh yeah
just a squirrel chasing a nut yeah like
you brought your kid to this episode
Matt yeah he was a nut it's my seed yeah
seed I thought you were making a
joke there's a kid right
there I like how he's wearing his like
Beats by Dre this would be an amazing
Beats by Dre commercial we're just like
nuts floe and there's like a kid right
there like hey shoulders knees and toes
knees and toes the wheels on the bus go
[Music]
around yeah yeah I got to I got to check
my jizz out maybe I'll do a 23 and me
you ever done that I did one yeah really
I I was drunk in a bar and a girl was
like I'll do it for you and she just
sent me one I did it and it was like
yeah it's it's nothing crazy what
ashkanazi Ash it's like everything on
you ashkanazi Jew oh holy oh
no Merry Christmas how you doing oh I'm
fantastic I've just been delivering
presents all the good girls and boys and
thought I'd come to visit you guys and
say hi did Jews get to celebrate
Christmas too oh yes wow no no presents
nothing no presents though you get to
watch us get presents baby yeah here you
go you got one of these re his eight
crappy gifts that equal one yeah there
you go what do you want OIC Santa you
look great oh yeah Santa's been a little
more fit he's on the keto a little bit
okay who invited Richard drus this is
great so how has everybody been great
great been a good boy been a good boy
he's been in public
oh I think that puts you on the naughty
list nah n n you already brought the
toys this is our ho ho ho that's me hey
how are you I'm good I'm also a jub at
half so Santa's been to my house break
the toy in half give it to her break it
in half give you half how's look at the
side with the batteries that home yeah
there you go very good Santa any stops
at Epstein's Island this year how was it
uh well there was many children but uh
here we go I decided to leave as quickly
as possible ha good look Santa I still
saw your name on the list
though like do you yeah did you slay any
puss all right always with the puns even
as a little kid you were always good
with oh yeah oh my dad hit
me what do you got in the bag anything
we can see oh I well yes uh how do you
guys like candy
canes we take that a
gun
oh boy jelly I'm a we should have gotten
a black Santa come on those are in right
now although they are very in right now
he would have been
late Sant are taking our
[Laughter]
job well I have let's see oh go so funny
what are you an out of work actor how'd
you get this
game oh that's fun oh yes whoa what the
how's that even possible it's called a
little bit of Christmas magic
Wow if you wouldn't be in public
so much you know a little bit more about
holy I want that toy yeah look at
that oh I see we're making it rain over
here hell yeah those the real hundreds
that was way more impressive than your
think
Santa yeah Matt did you happen to invite
uh Mrs Claus with giant fake
tits she has regular fake tits all right
we got two right here if you need them
oh nice two snowballs are those really
fake Bo large candy canes I have candy
canes if you would like them but it
sounds like it looks like you're already
sorry Sant I've gotten my toy I'll take
one yeah we got our sugar you like a
candy give j a candy cane something to
suck
on
yeah what a special Christmas this is
are you jealous of our people huh I bet
you wish you believed in Christ now
instead of killing him hey we did what
we had to
do yeah you had one Carpenter and he we
killed
him now we call
maintenance time of day for you head
back to the north yes I have many many
children to visit and uh a lot of them
on the good list this year so I'm going
to have to deliver some more presents it
was wonderful to see you oh hey is that
it you thank you all right someone plug
in Kevin Spacey's GPS
for the little boys you got the original
sweat shop over there in the North Pole
huh yes it's been very nice uh it's nice
cheap labor yeah um you just have to
feed them some milk and cookies that I
take from the houses that I come to so
it's pretty quite easy a lot of people
think that I eat them but now instead I
bring them so I can get some free labor
you know I just remember when I was a
kid I saw you my
mom yes that was very nice I thought it
was my dad how a wonderful wonderful
Christmas thank
you thank you Chris kingle thanks for
hitting Mark as a
kid made me a comedian all right well
that was cute that was super
wholesome minus all the fene stuff yeah
we we we dirted it up I forget that
you're Jewish what is that like around
this time you're what are you doing
wearing this I'm having fun I weating
our culture now I know that's our thing
bro hey I'm trying to stay in cognito
these are tough times
that's true I like how the only person
he didn't address was the 8-year-old in
the room he just
like yeah good well he's got to stay 10
ft
away no this time of year I mean
Hanukkah it's uh it's fun get the lotas
we we got our fun going on look
it's your time of year we're the
Hanukkah is a strong feature act be
Christmas is the we're getting by all
right in the middle you threw out lka
I'm like yeah that's H that's real funck
have you not had a lka what is that oh
the potato pancakes are great delicious
so good yeah are they I don't know
potato pancakes next time you're on
we're going to get some they're not good
no they're delicious they are
throw a little sour cream on them sauce
good we got we got tamales there
you go I'm going to have backup on this
soon trust me I mean love a potato
pancake Bring It On I'd like to try it
Eight Crazy Nights David tell you have a
bit about how uh his family was the
worst with Hanukkah they would take one
gift and stretch it over eight nights
they'd be like all right night one a
bike
handlebars I saw him last night at the
seller it's always fun to see I love his
joke I tell so you're you're in where in
Texas are you um I'm like outside of
Dallas I don't want to say where exactly
weirdos but you're uh but you're you you
thinking maybe moving here yeah right
yeah right now I've just been spending
like two weeks out of the month here but
once I get an apartment then I'll be
over here longer yeah why why not la can
I ask La is all right but I I mean my
main reason for moving here is just to
keep doing standup in front of like
strangers hell yeah yeah you need that
yeah I feel like my crowds are spoiling
me a little bit I get away with saying
stuff that's not even that funny but
they know me to the point we're like a I
don't know it's like doing comedy in
front of your cousins yeah you want to
you're a big fish and you want to you
want maybe I'll be a smaller fish for a
minute yeah well I wanted like a like I
don't know I don't want to say stuff
that only my crowd thinks is funny I'm
not going to feel funny you know what I
mean it's like making your friends laugh
like I want to make strangers laugh and
plus in New York you know you're like
diverse crowds and maybe it's just
feeding my ego but it feels good to make
just some like Swedish tourist laugh
yeah or like a you play you play enough
of those crowds you're like don't any of
you know the
language Norway again yippi I know
you're going to make me super
Republican we did a show together last
week and uh your crowd was there it
looked like a lot of your cousins yeah
out in the audience and then a fist
fight broke out yeah after the show what
yeah some guy named uh Muhammad I I'm
saying it like that cuz he wanted to
make sure I said it like that I was like
what's your name he's like Mo I was like
all right and he was just like well my
name is Muhammad but I didn't want you
to think anything about that and he was
just like just make sure you say it
right Muhammad yeah and then afterwards
uh like people were they're getting
really mad at him um for the record I
don't I'm not like on any side Israel
Palestine what this had nothing to do
with that no dog in the fight yeah but
uh yeah afterwards people were like
talking to him and he got one of
the wine bottles on the side of the wall
by the stairs at the at the City Winery
and he like smashed it on somebody's
head what I didn't know about that yeah
muhamed you're a bro
damn yeah damn that's but yeah that's
why I try to avoid like sharing a flyer
too much sometimes when I am in town so
I don't want it to just become like my
fans sure yeah holy I want I want other
people's fans I want more people like
that at the show he seems cool uh no
that's uh I know what you mean it's like
it is something like refreshing
especially with new material and it's
not your people and you're like oh this
is an accurate read that joke
stinks that's I to hear that oh yeah no
there's been there's been so many times
where I'm like man I think I got a new
five and then I do it here and I'm like
no don't it's just a five in front of my
crowd like right yeah you got make
strangers laugh nothing like a hot
weekend if you're like Madison Comedy on
State and they're just too good and
you're like I got a new 10 for sure then
I got a new 40 seconds Max I got n yeah
true also um I mean my crowds are mostly
always Latino but when I go from like
Texas towards the east like across the
South the Midwest up to the east coast
then they can get like different types
of Latino here like Puerto Ricans Domin
There Be Few black people a few white
people whatever and I know I can get
through a show with more of an accurate
read also I know I can get through like
a full show where I don't want to do
crowd work maybe I just want to do the
jokes yeah but once I once like once I
get to to like Texas going towards the
West it just becomes like all Mexican
crowds and I am getting a little tired
of like there's always there's always at
least one person or 20 people in each
show going George Lopez and I'm
like just me do jok oh man cuz you had a
little thing with him yeah but you guys
are cool now though or no I guess I
don't know I guess so that's the problem
with comedy on the phone everybody wants
the drama you know what's up with you
who you feuding with who is it they make
YouTube videos about it and it's it it's
annoying yeah I I just like damn I was
avoiding yeah like I was doing my best
to avoid getting compared to Lopez cuz I
feel like that's like the like I don't
know even when I was just open micing
people were like yeah going to be the
next Lopez right and I was like I don't
want to be the next Lopez um we're
starting a new show on a TBS called
Barbosa
tonight but yeah I was just trying my
best to avoid being compared to Lopez
but then Lopez brought up my name and I
now I have no choice yeah but that's
like that's toxic energy if they're if
they're it's like this isn't WWE it's
like we don't want to just like exact
I'm not doing a I'm not cutting a promo
I'm working on my ACT here you know yeah
and then one time one time people talked
about it one time somebody else at a
show and I was like nah it's cool me and
Lopez are cool he he called and
apologized and then this one guy was
like really mad he's like no he didn't
he never apologized to you I like all
right then he didn't you're the one that
brought it up bro what the you want
me to do like I don't I don't like when
people don't believe something I say
like if I have like a reason to lie
sometimes uh what what was I honestly
don't know what he did to you what did
he do um they they brought me up on a
podcast and all he all he I wasn't even
mad all he did was just they brought up
my name so much in this podcast that he
was just like who is that guy he's
like don't say his name on here him
which is like fine like that's his
podcast equipment he can say whatever he
want like yeah I'm I don't really care
also wasn't like a big Lopez fan I
wasn't like no like this all right
you you say what you want but yeah
Mexicans got real mad and I and I think
a lot of the Mexican crowds that come
out I think I have tons of Mexican fans
that just followed me cuz they followed
me but then I think there were so many
people that followed that found out who
I was because of him and following
because of him and I think a lot of them
especially like the older ones like in
San Antonio had like a lot of the older
Mexican guys and I feel like some of
them are just there out of hate for
George
Lopez it I'll take a fan sells
tickets yeah whatever but yeah you can
some Legend come out and say samel
please I want a bump right say it yeah I
don't know about a legend but I'll say
it but wait what was the phone call like
was that awkward um not really I
answered the phone
and he was like Whata n he didn't say
that how' he get your number uh through
this other dude named Edwin who like he
put together that like HBO Latino Film
Festival comp standup competition some
mouthful I don't know he puts he gets
Latinos together yeah and uh he was like
man he wants to call you or whatever I
was like yeah give him my number and he
just called me he was just like hey man
like it's it's George Lopez and I got I
got a little star shook I was like what
the he was just like yeah yeah he's
like listen listen and I was like oh
my bad man and then I said it again
I was like what the and he was like
no no no just listen man he's like I
want to apologize I was like you really
don't have to apologize man you're like
a veteran comic like you don't you don't
owe me an apology you're just shooting
the on your podcast it and he
was just like no man I got to apologize
like as a comic as a man like you know I
didn't know who you were yeah I was like
all right man I appreciate it I was like
you really didn't have to but appreciate
it and he was like now you got my number
you know fear need help or anything hit
me up so I don't know how many Mexican
fans you have but if you're out there
it's over we got a couple yeah yeah we
keep them in cages I mean I'm here
though I love this you tell this like
nice redeeming story and then you're
like let me get my gingerbread outfit on
yeah but yeah that's nice and he did it
I just think it's he can do whatever he
wants on his pod it's his pod whatever
but it's a weird instinct to just be
like who's this young new guy him
that's that's a weird even if you think
that it's is weird to say it out loud
makes you sound a little washed yeah bit
makes you sound yeah it makes you sound
like a little a lot of people well I
think on that same podcast cuz they were
were he was basically like yeah nobody
helped me so I don't help nobody which
I've heard is like his whole thing but I
don't think that's true not from I mean
then again it's just rumors I've heard
but didn't they say like Sandra bulock
helped him get his show oh I don't know
is that right Blindside yeah Blindside
speed Speed 2 yes I don't know what all
other movies she's made but the net the
net
Bird Box misong geniality recently Mis
yeah she had a run yeah I I don't know I
heard rumors that she kind of helped
them get his show going really pull that
up is that that that's interesting he uh
man that's interesting too it's like I
don't know also if someone didn't help
you you just go by The Motto I'm not
going to help anybody yeah how about you
go the other way I've seen Comics who
have had e easier roads than we have and
it doesn't influence how we treat them
yeah right that's weird we yeah I don't
know oh yeah they're they're pictured
together here and I also think
everyone's been helped I think that's
horeshit discovered there's no way yeah
you see look at that you're going to
tell me that's not help maybe she didn't
help them maybe they made a deal maybe
they were maybe she was like you
doing my landscaping for a year you got
a show buddy and then you know what I
heard I heard Carlos Mania did her
Landscaping the next year
crazy I got you three no that's
uh that's so weird that he say
that about you I don't I don't care I
knew there was a thing but I didn't know
what it was but uh that's weird yeah
what are you going to do what are you
going to do and if it got you a couple
fans who hate Lopez it yeah yeah
and you'll be nice to the next
generation of comics you know yeah yeah
yeah or not whatever maybe I'll be the
next Lopez for real okay no one no one
helped me Lopez on me I'm going to
on the next hot Latina comic but
on you is actually better than
giving you props I think cuz more Buzz
oh yeah the whole like reverse
psychology you tell somebody throughout
the trash they're not going to do it so
maybe he did help you maybe this maybe
this is what he was doing maybe George
Lopez is like like a real Mexican Jesus
Christ real Jesus there just sacrificed
himself for me he obiwan Kenobi Obi-Wan
you he obiwan obiwan me I like it I just
looked at him as he let himself get
struck by
that
commenters all right well there you go
Lopez but yeah it all right who were
some of the dudes when you were coming
up that you were like oh that's one of
my dudes has anyone reached out to you
like that like any like are the Vets the
older guys that reached out to me that I
was just like holy this guy reached
out you did you set yourself up for no I
was like I meant like vets I me like I
meant like of that of that generation B
Bert likes you is cool um you know who's
always like super awesome to me
just cool as hell let me open for him
give me advice this Dan Soder oh really
was badass great guy great great guy
great comic Big Jay let me play
basketball at his place hey yeah how is
I heard Jay's not bad at Hoops he's not
bad I mean not to be cocky but I whooped
everybody there are you good I did all
right uh I haven't played in like a few
months but at around that time I was
still playing pretty often yeah well big
J the chain wallet gets in the way it's
hard to play also everybody who played
was like smoking hell weed before the
game and I didn't I was like no I'm good
I want everybody had like a height
Advantage so I was like I'm not going to
be high and short like right right I was
I was playing yesterday outdoors with my
friend Dory and we're uh we're just like
shooting around and these two dudes
walked up to us with their girlfriends
and they were like you guys want to play
I'm like these guys they profiled
us little Asian we cook we
cooked in front of their girlfriends it
was So Satisfied I had something similar
like that happened and I got
just whooped really by some high
schoolers High School they're tough to
beat yeah they're so fast yeah they were
black they
cheated it does suck cuz we're playing
Rex centers on the road and some of
these kids can hoop oh yeah I
think we played actually in Dallas and
these kids were nasty they were doing
like all the new moves like some James
Harden back stuff I'm like what is this
car Lynch everybody hey happy holidays
new special on uh do you know Ralph yeah
I know you but we don't know each other
new special on Mark's YouTube that's
right it's cooking it's called queef we
queef week que we queef week I guess you
involved in the creative I didn't have
help that was all
her believe it or
not but yeah good we did the live chat
yesterday that's fun they loved you when
you jumped in I know sorry got cracking
that took so long puking all
day I really went too hard the night
before we did protect our Parks look at
Ari I took a shot of him
he's a 78y old man still going hard you
got to hand it to him why is it orange
uh I think we had
barbecue it's like Moses ex it's
extended the desert he couldn't make it
through 12
steps I could have made it through that
joke it would have been that was funny
can I get another coito and do you want
a cocktail or you uh driving no I'd love
a
cocktail please the special is over
let's do it I'm this is a big year for
specials you got a special I got a
special oh thank you we haven't even
plugged it yet Ralph special on
Netflix two hilarious Comics here so
definitely check them both out and hell
yeah and this is a special Christmas
episode you never know we already had
Santa show up you never know who's going
to pop in oh that's true that's true
what's your special called cabanga nice
thank you no queefs in it n none that
you can hear although his jizz is poison
we found out yeah he can't he can't
procore he's procreative but you can't
procreate anymore is what we found out
one and done what who told you the
doctor yeah and and you know women
yeah that's kind of a nice line though
to have with a woman you're like I can't
have babies so I guess we don't have to
wear a condo yeah I've said it and
they're like I'm going buy I'm going to
buy a plant b anyway and I'm like I'm
going I'm not going to pay for
it yeah what about I've done my part
yeah you're good you went to the doctor
you got got it checked out officially
yeah I just walk around with the
paperwork there you go just show the
girl right before you bang laminated
dude just throw it on the bar
table it just says most likely
not with a 20 on
it oh oh you're you're infertile right
you you're dead I mean I don't care
about children it's it's like I'm
infertile okay yeah I want a dog
infertile in the mine yeah going get a
comic with a dog can you pull that off
no no I I can't get one cuz my landlord
w allow it but and I don't want my
boyfriend to have to take care of it but
one day what kind of dog would we would
we Doh I don't even know what they're
called just something little and cute
and
playful something that doesn't too
big thank
you cheers cheers hey hey what is this
comedy it's like an eggn I'm Puerto
Rican I don't know where everyone's like
from different Spanish backgrounds oh
yeah oh yeah you you got Spanish
background right I'm from Spain Spain
that's the original Spanish
oh yeah Spaniard well thank you
this is scary this must be how black
people on white
people you took us over I know everyone
says that then and then it gets so
awkward I want to apologize can in
Spanish can I can I do sets in Spanish
I've never tried it what try it right
now n n Mexicans hate my Spanish how the
PUO cross the road or
whatever a dude Mexicans judge your
Spanish so hard oh right right everyone
judges I have a special coming out on
Friday and I they're going to like rip
me apart it's in Spanish yeah oh
yeah the Spanish people cuz I I talk
like an 8-year-old Spanish girl I lived
there till I was eight it's going to be
they're going to here's what sucks too
and I get jealous of it is people whose
first language is not Spanish when they
do comedy in Spanish like Spanish
speakers love it like Mexicans love to
hear like Tom Sor in Spanish they love
it yeah because they're being like
vulnerable but like if I speak Spanish
and then I get words wrong they're like
you you're supposed to
know this like disappointed dad do
you think it's cuz you're darker than
cigara is that oh for sure yeah it's cuz
I look like I should be able to and I
and I don't you know what I mean it's
like watching a 7 foot two person miss a
basket what do you mean you can't dunk
you idiot is playing with house
money that's the yeah smart thank you
that's the Spanish one Give a listen to
this
see
sounds like you're mocking a Spaniard I
know it does I'm mocking my mother oh
okay it's funny CU it's still the facial
expressions are still funny there's
there's things that still translate your
Spanish is your Spanish is pretty good
though cuz it's Spanish Spanish like
Spanish Spanish it's Spanish it's the
vocabulary that throws me off I say the
wrong thing every once in a while and it
comes out more sing songy than my
English comedy my vocabulary and my like
accent it's just like I don't know I'll
stop now all I'm disappointed enough
mexic I almost asked for more ice then I
didn't want to offend you guys get some
ice in
here well that's nice couple of
Spaniards I if I had to know one
language it would be Spanish yeah
because you guys are really taking over
if you had two yeah we are yeah nice
you're coming in I mean give it come
handy in New York yeah I mean what about
about Italian no one uses that Chinese
would come in handy I want to know what
they're saying about me in those
restaurants oh yeah good point yeah they
are mean they're mean the meaner a
Chinese server is the the better the
food is going to be it's good point
Chinese could be big though I mean I
feel like if you're touring you're
looking at now I'm I'm getting agenty on
you you hit Shanghai you're making some
money that's true that's true
yeah there's a million of them yeah or
more than that Japanese I want to learn
Japanese they got cool cars they got
like arcades everything's cute Yeah
Hello Kitty I'm I'm I get intimidated
easy I don't get intimidated by Japanese
stuff you know nah that's so hard to
learn though that would take so long and
but they blur their porn what oh yeah
yeah what bring it up pull it up what is
the point of the porn going to blur it
well they're a repressed people what
keep the kid on the other side of the TV
for this I've never been more angry at
America until I found that I feel like
that's our fault no we don't blur it but
we knew and we just traumatized them and
now they're bluring porn we we've
roasted all their genitals this clip
right here is where Matt loses custody
divorce roll the clip where he's
searching Japanese
penises his wife's like I'll take full
custody yeah uh Japan is I mean Kyoto is
supposed to be beautiful yeah yeah I
mean
it's a beautiful Nation but
that's supposed to be like that's where
like the billionaires like that's where
like Steve Jobs would go on vacation as
a Kyoto oh come on Kyoto is where you
see the like the real geishas really
yeah whoa the old timey like call girls
I went to China I know it's not Japan
but I went to China and I we had a tour
guide and uh he was like a fat ugly guy
with like a wolverine t-shirt and long
stringy hair and I go what what what got
you here he's like the like he
just came out with he's like I can't get
laid in America so I moved here and I
was like all right I respect the honesty
that is weird but he's like I
clean up cuz I'm a different yeah I'm a
5 foot 11 white guy just being different
will get you laid oh yeah it's like
being black here Dick's a little bigger
you know you feel taller You Can Dance a
little it's a whole different world but
that's true for comedy too don't you
think if you like moved to New Zealand
you'd be huge well you guys are huge but
no that's true Arch Barker yeah proof of
that Parker who's that oh he was huge
when I was a kid he was big in Australia
before I feel like the internet like
yeah it was I feel like now a lot of
comics can sell tickets overseas just
because of YouTube but there was a time
when you know you had to kind of go
there and build an audience and he he
was one of the early guys right you knew
him a little bit didn't you a little
they played Comedy Central over there
and for some reason his just caught you
know sometimes like you do really good
like Drew Cary apparently was huge in
Japan as well yeah I want to build a fan
base like in Japan or like China just
but like I don't know some I don't know
I even if it was just like 50 people and
just film like a special with an all
Japanese audience or I'm just like your
agent I'd advise you against this being
your next special I'm I'm going to go
for it but I just think it'd be
hilarious just to see me be like and
then my grandma was like yeah and a
bunch of Japanese people be like ah
yeah well Japanese and Mexican I think
there a lot of similarities you like
rice uh you like rice that's about it
that was like the classic Norman setup
but it just ran out of steam tiny penis
I always felt like we went along good
like we relate to uh Irish people oh
really yeah cuz I I saw I was watching
some movie I forgot I forgot what movie
it was I just remember the guy saying
like I'm Irish like we don't talk we
don't go to therapy we drink or
something and then what was it on
Goodwill Hunting when they're like I
heard you got an Irish curse oh yeah
like every time they describe Irish
people I'm relating so
hard yeah I don't think Mexican you're
not big into therapy that's not part of
the culture I know you you drink you
don't tell your son you love him and you
know you drink some more there you go go
to work that's just a New York thing I
think what therap yeah therapy yeah for
sure Woody Allen really pushed and then
it turned out he was the most up
as all also therapists are the most
crazy I mean like I've done it a lot but
I've also realized most of the craziest
people in my life are therapists yeah
are therapists yeah I have a
complet and there's a completely insane
person I know that is a therapist there
another one I got attacked by a
therapist in Vermont he broke a
Pine glass over my head got arrested
he's not going to be practicing for the
next few years the did you tell him
I thought it was well I didn't say
anything that bad what happened
was what Happ I was trying to do this
bit about how Mexicans and Japanese
people are
like and it just didn't go over no I uh
I we just kind of exchanged a few words
it was nothing that bad but he was in a
blackout and he went for he went for a
cop's gun he was he was what he was
hoping for suicide by cop he was going
through an ugly divorce and he blacked
out and it was like you know he should
talk to a therapist yeah right that's
the best kind of therapist what would
you learn from like a normal person you
need a really up person to learn
so take it from me Tred to commit
suicide by
cops but it's like how a lot of cops are
actually corrupt they're actually
criminals themselves they they go
together it's a yin and a Yang so most
therapists are helping you with your
up
what are you looking for in therapy when
you guys
go a little Clarity this is because of
this that's why you do that it it helps
you realize why you do things and why
you are the way you are bre Breaking Bad
patterns you want to break bad patterns
that's where you go I think that's a lot
of it just crying making sense
offf oh yeah for 15 years do you see
Allan I see his wife oh oh Beth there's
a comedian therapist in New York Ralph
wait there's a comedian therapist
there's a
like specifically for Comics it's like
the comedy shell you need two recks and
actually my boyfriend sees Allan and
then I one day I was like damn it I
can't see him CU you know you can't
really share oh really a therapist as a
couple it's not a good idea oh but it's
just it's it's not illegal but it's
found Theon type thing well yeah because
they're kind of biased they want to stay
on one side and it worked out for Tony
Soprano and Gloria trillo right yeah one
of you going to kill yourself you know
yeah well I like I like his wife it's
you know she's in the family so she's
good oh okay there you go yeah I know
therapists a lot of them have therapists
which feels weird yeah feels like a Ser
like an anxiety dog with an anxiety dog
yeah but it's like they practice what
they preach at least it's like okay well
I at least believe true true true I've
never gone to a therapist and honestly
like I'm trying to see how long I can go
without going to
one well we'll see when that school gets
shot
up you think I'd go through to school
come on you're right what a bank maybe
you seem pretty stable though yeah you
are put together n you don't show it I
will I will like wait till I'm at the
hotel and then I'll eat so many
mushrooms really and destroy a hotel
room and cause so much noise that I'll
almost just cause like a TMZ Scandal and
what lose gigs but we could have been
hanging out years ago I haven't yet okay
I didn't know this side of you yeah I
try to hide it that's why I didn't
really want to do too much on like on
like birds thing yeah yeah but then like
the one night I finally did mushrooms I
did what I always do on mushrooms I just
keep eating more and more and it was
still fun though I had a good time made
a few racist jokes and yeah it was all
right you know yeah boy we're one and
the same yeah but no yeah there's times
where I'm just like I'll go too far
especially if I like drink and get some
mushrooms you guys asked me to bring
like two recommendations bring us a rack
yeah with one honestly that's that's the
two things I could recommend the most
mushrooms and racist jokes I guess that
too I was going to say mushrooms and
beer oo oh yeah that's nice I've never
had a bad night on mushrooms and beer
what's your what's your beer uh I think
modelos maybe Budweiser I like
Budweisers a lot the the heavy not the
light you like the Negro Modelo yeah I
like that one too I like the light ones
I like Miller lights yeah pills it's
hard it's hard to find the beer I don't
like I like pbrs a lot mhm yeah I don't
think I've ever had a beer I just didn't
like maybe Bud Light I don't really like
Bud Light too much okay what about uh
Guinness I like Guinness I like Guinness
I like you you only have three of them
yeah but I like them i' the first time I
had a Guinness was here in New York I
didn't even really become a drinker to I
started hanging out in New York yeah
makes a lot of sense yeah my friend who
started doing comedy with me in Dallas
he moved out here really early on and so
I'd come and crash on his couch every
now and then just to hit mics or
whatever and find out what I'm into out
here his roommate ended up being
unemployed his roommate worked for the
doctor all show for a while it's my
buddy Jake sh out to Jake but then that
show you know went and uh my buddy did
it go off the air cuz he ran for office
is that why I don't know I never really
asked maybe but yeah my buddy was just
free all day while my actual friend
Fernando would be at work all day so me
and Jake would just hang out and do
Mike's go showcases and then that dude
would just hang out at bars all night
and so I couldn't go home I didn't have
a key to their apartment so I couldn't
come home until Jake went home so I just
hang out with him it's like I said in
that one joke like you're not going to
be at the bar and not drink right so I
just you know became like a drinker
there you go it was nice good to have
fell in love with dive bars oh I love a
dive there's something kind of special
about a dive right it's the bet I go on
the road and they're like where do you
want to go after this this great
nightclub or this place is like The Hot
Spot I'm like H a hotot any bar
where you can't have a conversation
sucks I mean it's like all we have is
our personalities that's why I always
hated those Festival parties where it be
like it's all Comedians and it' be
like just like techno and you're like I
like that after a certain point once I'm
a certain amount of drunk I don't want
to talk anymore yeah me and that guy
huh Al is your kids an EDM
kid especially once I'm hallucinating we
we were in Austin a while back and uh
that was my first time trying Molly oh
like I was like a little drunk I some
Molly had some mushrooms and had like
these lasers and it was
pretty cool yeah Molly is great it just
got a little weird because there's like
these like hot chicks right I want to do
drugs we're we're such a bad influencer
drug I don't I don't do drugs you don't
you've never done Molly or acid or
anything none of that stuff I'll do I
mean I do I do the most old man drugs I
do muscle relaxers for you
know I want to try those I I do that's
where I'm like all right I'll be on a
flight muscle axer whiskey that's that
sounds badass I like yeah I love wh
these psychedelics that help you figure
out those are supposed to be I mean
you can but I don't like that's not what
I like to use it for no it's just fun
yeah sometimes people are like do you
feel more in tune with living
organisms no he just hallucinated like
crazy yeah I just laughed a lot exactly
like Rick and Morty or something dumb
you never did drugs no just iasa that's
it just IA
sorry I know
what I mean that I told Ari I'd do his P
like we talk about it um like next week
but uh I went to Peru by myself like a
month ago two months ago and just went
for it went to the Amazon by
myself holy did iasa and now I want
to go backwards and do like the lighter
ones like shrooms and all that never
doneit what is aasa exactly I've never
even heard of this sounds like it's a
Vine that's mixed with a with different
trees I mean someone else will tell you
better but it's basically a mixture from
the Amazon jungle and you drink it and
you see a lot of what' you see a
lot of come
onor save it for AR no no you're not
even really supposed to share it
like one of those like you you work
out kind of stuff but is that do you
work it out is it worked out Chris Rock
that he became religious after Iowaska
that was Neil Brennan oh sorry Neil
Brennan
sorry there's there's stuff that you I
mean you definitely wrestle with the
Devil with the demons inside of you that
sounds like not a fun experience that
but you come out of it the on the other
side I went on a date with a girl once
who said it's 10 years of therapy in one
day I'm like that's too much therapy
yeah and yeah but after 4 hours it's
over that's that's pretty nice I guess
it's not like you don't have a hangover
did you puke all oh yeah uh oh oh yeah
from all ends oh you do all ends you had
diarrhea too have you done it no but I I
like the person that I know that did it
did it the same way as you yeah yeah
yeah you got to go all into the jungle
and do it you don't after that like you
just feel like super cleansed after that
like you just let it all out yeah and
it's it's uh it I don't think it takes
one ceremony to figure it out oh no
that's how they get you a
pyramid got to keep going back so I need
to go
tonight I got more to figure out
Dam everybody who I've heard does it
loves it yeah Matt Ruby does it right
he's done it like five times I mean you
love it after you do it you don't love
it during not every habit needs to be a
self-destructive nightmare give yourself
the gift of a good habit this Christmas
with fume fume gives that nasty hand to
mouth habit a serious upgrade by taking
away the stinky the Bad and the
dangerous Parts but letting you keep
keep the Habit itself fume is an
Innovative award-winning device instead
of vapor fume uses flavored Air instead
of electronics fume is completely
natural instead of harm harmful
chemicals fume uses delicious flavors
you get the point it's an all-around
better way for dealing with the
stressers of Life Mark you love this
stuff oh yeah something nice I got an
oral fixation it's nice to just suck on
this puppy it tastes good we got a lot
of good flavors I like it it's smooth
it's wet waxi it's a beauty hell of a
mouthpiece it takes the original and
levels it up with a premium Walnut
barrel and a smooth coating on that Onyx
Black mouthpiece start the holidays off
right with the good habit by going to
fume do sorry trif nume.com drunk that's
TR yum.com drunk and getting the journey
pack today fume is giving listeners of
the show 10% off when they use the code
drunk to make to help making starting
the good habit that much easier there
you go
fume hey sit down we got you the the bit
chair there chair than you another
very funny comedian with a new special
Lou
cats and I need some backup they were
trashing lck CU Louis so I they are like
a like a just just above a hash brown
sometimes when they're poorly done but
when they're done right there we go that
makes them sound more delicious just
above a hash brown I love a hash brown
better than a hash brown better than a
hash brown they're better than a hash
brown hell yeah I'm going try that
little little egg in there makes it
light oo baby yeah all right we got to
get back to
Christmas temp we just lost all our
listen Palestinian fans checked out you
want a drink uh sure what do you got
cookie dough cookie dough to
drink he whed it up make it for you and
you'll figure it out all right it's like
a Puerto Rican eggnog okay I've never
even had regular eggnog I sex move yeah
I gave her a Puerto Rican egg doog end
up quoting davel's eggnog bit which he
just calls elf
yeah why why poured in glass just rubs
pour it on my back and call it a night I
think is the tag yeah love it do you
guys know each other yeah yeah yeah he
actually did a a guest Set uh for a tell
in Dallas I saw him right away I was
like you know usually you see everyone's
kind of good these days but no one's
that good I saw him I was like Blown
Away first time I saw really and I I
went up driving like that was so I was
like gushing it was kind of embarrassing
how much I like him this the dudee that
got me into the seller yeah my god look
this yeah my only but the one person I
recommended I'm like this isn't even a
risk he should be at the seller and that
was easy you know man they asked me I
was like don't don't bring him in there
I've wrecked a few people at the seller
there was one comic I was like a little
nervous about and I remember texting
Michael CH I'm like can you wreck this
guy your buddies with him and he did and
the guy didn't get past I like thank God
that's on that's I mean really you're
lucky you got in with my recommendation
I now I need you to recommend me to the
seller is really the
truth it's so scary to recommend someone
to the seller unless they're like you
know the perfect person still regret
Matt
re just kidding he's actually I think
he's in is he mhm I'm sure he could he
did a set there little last week I'm
sure he did with Kevin Hart oo yeah wow
was that I wasn't there I can't wait to
see your
guys's this is it
we might be drunk the
movie it's actually you're joking but
we're working on it really yeah we are
working on the movie oh that's awesome
but I oh sorry no go ahead well I did a
set with Chappelle at the stand and rock
and Kevin Hart and they're all in the
green room and it was it was a Real Love
Fest so they really do have this you
know lift each other up thing yeah yeah
I just did I just did uh the noted too
many St thing I was late at as I said
earlier but like rock is so nice he's
he's such a nice guy you know it's cool
that he's like one of the best ever but
he's also like he's he's every time he
speaks you're like I got to reeval my
whole life yes secret yeah like
a few years ago he did an interview like
when one of his specials came out I'm
like this interview could be a whole
another special like it's all funny it's
all like crazy like dropping knowledge
it was it was it was amazing my favorite
Chris Rock quote I don't remember where
I saw this I might be making it up to
make myself feel better about my
decisions but I'm pretty sure I saw him
say this where he said that uh if like
at my funeral people are talking more
about how great I was at standup than
than how good I was as a father it's
like then I really fa and so ever since
then I'm like all right let me make more
decisions about my son yeah stand up you
know and that's when your act took a
dive I thought you were G to say he said
uh if they're talking more about uh that
I'm better as a standup than I am as an
actor I'm like that's that's is going to
happen that is what's GNA
happen yeah not a great actor
see that movie top five movies I haven't
seen that one I've heard that's great I
love that part where he sees DMX and DMX
trying to sing a great he's just like oh
I should stick to what I know
that's a great scene in the Seinfeld and
the strip club scene holy oh I
forgot some great Rock You know it's a
pretty good movies in he's really good
in uh this movie called Nurse Betty
remember that one oh yeah like Renee
zeler it's like a drama like a serious
drama right it's a dark comedy yeah yeah
or maybe that's totally off made it it
was good huh you saw that Sal which one
is it Nurse Betty no I never saw it oh
you're like the film guy here yeah he
was also the president in some with
Bernie Mack remember president yeah that
one was tight I like that Bernie Mack
was the the best Bernie Mack in
that movie
um what is it called Soul no soul
brothers or what it called Samu L
Jackson yeah soulman soulman soulman I
liked anything Bernie ma did I like the
baseball one he did I like 3000 dude wow
saw oh I just I just like I just liked
watching him you know Mac Show I just
enjoyed him yeah whatever happened to
M so many Comics died have you seen that
movie life love life when he comes out
he's all with with the up eyes
like I'm the
Peppe yeah that was great great
movie I you know what rock one is kind
of underrated is a I think I love my
wife I thought that was actually like
you didn't like
was it's okay all right all right thank
you remake of a Euro movie I thought it
was good yeah yeah likey got shot in the
face no it's a call back we were talking
Bushi earlier but he's he's the friend
oh yeah he's the funny friend then he
was in rain on me oh no that was cheel
yeah with Adam Sandler so racist sorry
no but everything Rock speaks and like
he has these like philosophies where
you're like damn this dude's
just you just I shut the up and I'm
like let this guy just talk oh cuz he's
going to say that you're like huh
well there's black people
and anytime I'm around any like veteran
Comics that I really like I try my best
not to talk just listen I feel like if I
just listen like I'll find out things
that I've always been curious about
anyway yeah that's how I met
Cosby what there's also that thing where
like this kind of sucks you have to kind
of play cool whenever in those
situations so you can't really enjoy it
like you want to really be like this is
awesome you want to like freak out you
got to be like like hey what's up you
know just act normal and it's not normal
you got to wear Gingerbread Man
suits that was like that night at the
seller when they all came in at once you
remember and it made it in the paper oh
yeah it was like it was Amy aiz
Chappelle Rock Seinfeld and I was just
me sitting at the table with Robinson
first and and I think that's when he was
wasn't Jerry like I like Al bit and
until was like did you
he's was it clean
enough there there's a great scene in
Comedians and Cars with Zack gofan AIS
and he's like oh man a tell he's like
the best comic ever and Simon's like
yeah and he goes well you don't like a
tell and he goes he was mean to me
once and they kept it in I got to say
wow that's great yeah he kept it in
that's surp I find that show to have
like not enough dirt and too much
cutaways of coffee machines and that's
uh that's that's way better I wish I
speak for yourself those coffee
machines I just want to watch more beans
dude yeah right um no that's that's
crazy he kept that in I didn't know that
he kept a lot in he kept when he trashed
uh Bobcat go weight oh yeah he did that
on purpose yeah I mean he wanted him to
know that was uncomfortable Bob is like
the nicest Dude too it was a weird uh I
guess they just have a history but well
he goes at them pretty hard Have you
listened to the rant it's pretty wild
isn't it kind of like an comic versus
Club comic kind of thing like he thinks
he's all weird and I'm just doing real
comedy real comedy as he puts it right
right he's like you got you got to light
the Tonight Show couch on fire I'm doing
jokes over here yeah yeah yeah you got
to do a voice so you know not to get
into it I like the when he when he uh
that clip that goes around about it with
Norm doing the Cosby joke which is like
I love that he kept that in too that's
such a great joke great joke great joke
oh man what is it Paton Oswald said uh
the hypocrisies would bother me the most
he's this clean comic you know and Norm
goes I think the the
rape Sor now do you think Cosby's Legacy
will be hurt yeah you do being and Pat
oswal he told me I think the worst part
of The Cosby thing was the
hypocrisy and I
disagreed I thought it was the
raping that's just so I mean it's just
so Norm it's like he was so good at
cutting right to the real I just
rewatched his last special and uh the
one the one no not reading hit dog
Hitler's dog last live one but uh the
bitt he does about sarcasm about how you
can just reply you can give the truth
but sarcastically like yes yes honey I
want to your sister you got me and
I want to murder you yes that's and he
just keeps going for like 3 minutes God
the fact that he extends it for 3
minutes yeah that's what he did it's so
great and like I was um I recently I
tried to submit a tape for The Tonight
Show recently and uh they said I was too
um grumpy and
negative and I was like well you know I
was thinking what of my favorite late
night appearances I've seen recently
it's got to be bur uh Burr or Norm I'm
like oh those were all on Conan and
that's another big loss to the comedy
community is that how Conan would let
have stuff like that on even though
that's not his style but he still had it
on you know yes cuz it was funny yeah
yes but The Tonight Show but every comic
is grum
that's what comedy is I'm like if you
want me to be clean then I got to be
grumpy and negative I either dirty or
I'm grumpy and negative that's it you
know great Point guy yeah Conan also is
I mean of Our Generation maybe the
greatest straight man ever I mean the
way he would react to Burr the way he
would react to Norm it was like he set
him up yeah he let him outrage and it
made it funnier he be like well that's
not okay just keep her going it was
perfect he just Conan just understands
comedy on such a great love I mean I I
love this is a great one have you seen
this who's that Jim Downey and I feeler
Unapologetic about being Conan O'Brien's
friend wait are we going to watch this
whole thing no no no there's a clip I
know the clip you're going for the
Epstein clip yeah I think is it no this
is like a 30 minute thing it's on tuse
you're slipping behind those keys my
friend and as a
father what's what's his
name much said you're doing great Matt
yeah there you go pull pull back here
Epstein the New York
nnc hold on hold on hold on much has
been said much has been said about
Jeffrey Epstein Terrible Things Jeff I'm
talking about Jeff Epstein the New York
finer we're talking about the same Jeff
Epstein no yes
no what I never I never heard oh it was
a big story in the news huge no yes for
you to say no one ever said yes Jeff
fste yes the finance with the island yes
he had an island that I've never been to
yeah I I'm pretty sure with respect if
there was some news about Jeff Epstein I
would have heard no I
know it keeps going but like I mean dude
so that guy it's Jim Downey is it yeah I
heard once I was on the road with
Sandler and all those SNL guys were like
talking they were like that was the guy
you wanted to impress on SNL like that
figher so I mean I think he's like a
legend yeah he's like he's like was on
the 20 years he's behind all the like
the really great stuff that's aome I
have to watch this one I haven't seen it
I gotta watch that too yeah yeah yeah K
I want Conan on here oh I love Conan
he's so
friendly I didn't Conan yeah he comes
right to the green room most of them
yeah you did Letterman I did twice twice
so cool does that make me sound so old I
know it totally does that's great but
right at the end pull it up there's that
thing about doing something right before
they cancel the show and then it
immediately becomes a dated credit
you're oh my God like yeah you can't use
it anymore yeah yeah brutal yeah I
remember Letterman gave you the the hand
kiss right I was like in and
then the second one I was like is he
going to kiss
it and he kissed it you need another
drink there sloppy jeloy are you all
right
to die in his arms cuz I think that
would be
romantic but we're not together
anymore so now it's just going to be
awkward that was the best best audience
was letter oh I know their audiences
were the best and this is when you're
young and
castable come on what about
now you did you've done have you done
late night I did did The Tonight Show
went viral I wanted to do I wanted to do
Conan when I first started doing comedy
and then like my second month into
comedy he was like I'm a
retire brutal that was the best one they
you flew out to LA they put you in that
Hilton it was that was nice and and you
could
curse the only note they ever gave me
was I I had a joke where I wish cancer
on someone they're like you can't you
can't wish cancer on his National
audience I was like that's a fair note
it's R it's a fair note like that's very
you get away with anything on that yeah
the only I had a joke about me getting
raped and they were like nah no but I'm
like it's me though I get rap can't do
it Conan was the best that was the best
one to do definitely what's the platform
now seriously like there isn't a lot of
cuz we don't even know it's all in flux
right now also right they're moving
things around or yeah well I think it's
just you get like a big Tik Tok or a big
uh Instagram clip or YouTube clip that's
now it I mean same with comedy movies
like no one watches those they just go
watch Tik Tok for 2 hours they're going
to watch watch ours we got that right
when does it come out well we haven't
sold it yet two three years we're going
to sell it do is it written in a way
that you could shoot it yourselves if
you wanted to no okay we don't know
we're doing we're shooting for a budget
here all right okay okay I know the name
of the movie are you afraid somebody Ste
the name don't say it someone to steal
called Epstein's
Island by the way you guys are huge in
Spain I just went to Spain yes and
everyone's
like we might be drunk oh wow Ser that's
awesome damn the only reason we had you
on is get the Spain fans
where and the seller is
[Music]
like wow I want to go to Spain oh yeah
you want go to
mexical I'm trying to what nothing yet
it's tough cuz it's like at first you
don't make the money or like it's a lot
of I mean it's cool to travel but you're
also like it there's there's value in
waiting to you can actually sell some
tickets over there you know cuz I I just
did Australia for the first time and we
we got offers like you went years ago
yeah but for the festival yeah this was
different I want to go just I want to go
to different European countries just to
see if I could get the laughs like I'm
not too worried about the money but I
want to make sure I can go and like be
funny over there it's different I don't
I mean like I've only done like
Continental Europe I haven't done
anywhere where they English is their
first language and you know because
Europeans move all over because the
European Union the you know common
language is English but I think there's
like fluent English and then I think
there's comedy English yeah and they
just don't get every joke so every
European door I done is like it's just a
process of slowly dumbing down my ACT
until it's the most basic jokes and then
I'm just kind of bored now I mean I'm
not doing you're doing in the native
language I think is probably awesome
like it's totally when I do English
jokes in Europe I same thing they're
either expats and they get it or their
first generation and you're like have to
speak a little slower yeah you kind of
have to you know figure it out as you go
you got to change your references don't
say Target say their grocery or whatever
especially doing like Latino in Spanish
too like the they don't use the same
words oh yeah oh yeah you know and then
the I mean the best English there is is
in all the Scandinavian countries so
they get it more but they don't feel
emotions so they don't laugh at things
and then that's not fun either you know
like
Scandinavians they're the happiest I did
our uh Amsterdam and they're good but
they it's a lot of clapping more than
laughing and they I'm not going to say
who but they had two huge Comics who we
all respect before me and both of them
snapped on the audience really and guys
you're like that guy SN Michael Richard
sna that's not like him but yeah that
was a shocker that was uh yeah I
remember I used to watch all those David
tell Insomniac apps and that was like
the one where he's like I'm
bombing oh Dam well you know the
thing is I think they're like they're
permissive about sex because they think
it's not a big deal so if you try and do
these sex jokes they're like we do not
care I I can do their accent I'm doing
like a French one but you know someone
can someone else do the accent for me
it's not shocking to that yeah it's yeah
it's not it's not even interesting it's
just sex like whatever we all do it we
all ERS who cares that's why I went
straight
Holocaust that's still shocking they're
like and Frank over there just spend
like a month there do comedy for like
the last two weeks like get a simulated
first I
that a bunch of H go to Edinburgh
you'll get us later yeah get to
Edinburgh I'm I'm going try to go there
yeah I want to do that are you going to
do that yeah I hope so full month I
don't know if I have the boss for that
two weeks at least two weeks I would
do two weeks you can do two weeks you
did a month I did a month yeah it was
great like it yeah I know it was fun and
it's it's packed people go to shows all
the time they're wasted you learn a lot
about your it's like comedy Camp really
see that's what I wanted yeah yeah all
right maybe I'll do the month but you
could you're in a place now you could
probably also just do a tour in for for
that many days in in a row you but
that's what I'm saying like what if I
what if I what if I have people come out
for the for the tour and but then I'm
like like not funny to them I don't want
people to waste money just for like a
mediocre
show yeah you'll be funny what do you
what do you mean you're funny you a fan
base they're going to come to see you I
don't know if I have one in Scotland you
have a huge fan base in Scotland sure
come back from
Scotland scotlands and Mexicans have a
lot in
common
the
rice not to not to not to like
disrespect my own people but I'm going
to be really pissed off if I go to
Scotland and it's an all Mexican crowd
I'm
godamn get away from you people damn you
guys dig
tunnels you got to build a
wall is there sorry sorry well let me
just ask this is there cuz you're a a I
don't want to say a niche but you're a
Mexican comic I mean you're comic but
you are Mexican keep worse do you is
there perks to that where you're like
hey I got a little novelty here I'm a
little different or is it like I'd
rather just be just let me be me who
what do you mean like who am I different
from well I mean you have you have
Mexican fans they go he's Mexican he's
funny I like this guy yeah I got Mexican
fans I don't know if I have Mexican fans
you got a few really yeah you do really
I'm just gonna say that but I think you
do well I I I think oh Chopper was a big
fan of your out of comics out of comics
that I've taken pictures with or
whatever like come out on shows with
when like or like when I even even when
I got to open for you like I think
you're the comic that Mexicans bring up
the most often like y I saw you work
with that wow that's nice well like I
know a guy who's Indian he's a friend of
mine he's a comic and he's always like
ah it sucks being an Indian comic CU I'm
like the Indian guy I want to just be a
comic but then also there's people who
are like hey this is great I get like
the Indian fans it's but it's the
writing I mean you're writing you your
jokes are just solid jokes I think you
have there's it's real Universal uh
nature to the way you write jokes same
with Shang Wang like Shang sure he gets
the advantage of having all these Asian
fans especially because he came up under
alley but it's he also is big in the
midwest cuz he's clean and doing
observational stuff so weird when I go
to the Midwest my Crowds Are a little
more split a little more diverse it's
probably just a more it's just more
white people in that area probably right
yeah too I'm just glad that that the
seats are at least filling up with
somebody yes of course yeah but like
what I was saying earlier when I get the
older Mexican the crowds I think they're
the ones that are expecting me to maybe
do like a more George Lopez right like
Paul what is it name Paul Rodriguez type
like yeah you know us Mexicans yes um
and then and then you can see it during
the show where they're just like what's
this guy talking
about dogs they want you to start every
joke with I'm Mexican yeah so but when
they're closer to my age then then it's
a little better you know yeah I feel
like I'm still doing
comedy that most like Latinos can relate
to without having to say like yo first
of all I'm Latino yeah yeah right it's
and that's also like I I love uh Felipe
sparza but in the in the beginning it
was more Universal jokes and I think as
he got a Latino F base he's doing more
he knows his fan base of Latino and he
directs The Comedy towards that more so
I kind of miss the old Felipe although
he still I still think he's hilarious
he's a great joke right one of my
favorite Felipe jokes is where he says
that uh he two kids and he had his first
kid when he was a teenager when he was
in high school he's like I still
remember when my girlfriend told me she
was pregnant he was like it was
Wednesday Pizza
day he's like she came to my table she's
like Filipe I'm pregnant he's like I got
my tray I moved to another
table that's one of those jokes that I
feel like can relate to Latinos without
having to say like I'm Latino like you
know what I mean like we we did that
show in Montreal where we had to riff
for like 20 minutes which is just all
you had you couldn't do material and
just to that coming out oh I know and uh
Felipe went on last and just killed it
like he was so effortlessly just like
what's up with you and just funny funny
funny murdering he's a pro we tried to
get him on the P I think he was hung
over or something fipe is on on my
comedy Mount Rushmore also because every
time I see him he gives me free
mushrooms hey perfect yeah but he he's
one of those people it's like his
charact his whole Persona is funny and
then he's also a good writer it's like
Cat Williams to me
you know like every their whole Essence
is funny and then the things they're
saying are all they could just be like
clowns and be funny but they're also
telling well-written jokes and it's
pretty amazing that is the Perfect combo
yeah Bernie Mack was like that yeah sure
yeah totally Brodney Brodney funny
looking sounding F topper AR He Man Yeah
Yeah just all gold even just when he
walks out I tried to do that on my first
cuz I I notice when he does late night
he walks out and he kind of like like
he's lost he's like
hey and I tried to do that on my first
one but I I think I just looked lost
like it didn't look funny it just looked
like I didn't know what I was
doing it's funny Michael Richards I'm a
huge Seinfeld the show fan I have to
bring it back to the nword but he said
when he was on the show s he didn't
really know he knew I was the wacky
neighbor but I didn't really know where
to go and then he said on like the third
episode he figured out I'll be the dumb
guy but I'll pretend to be the smart guy
so I'll I'll act smart even though I'm
actually doing dumb and that's when
he figured out Kramer like I'll be
confident but still an idiot a confident
dumb guy is funny it's funny it's really
yeah it is really funny yeah it's it's
weird watching those old episodes of a
show where they the character is so well
done and pronounced later on and then
you watch the early ones you're like oh
they haven't figured it out yet this is
weird you know it's like a comic you got
to find that voice yeah you watched an
old Homer's voice you're like what the
oh yeah the animation's real bad
it's kind of slow there's not many jokes
it's like that first season is rough
it's still some good episodes in that
first season but it's like yeah it's not
what it became for sure it's better when
it gets weirder and there's like tons of
jokes and the first one I think it was
trying to be just an animated sitcom
instead of like being like let's take
advantage of this animation and go like
Buck Wild you know once it goes to like
season three and forward I feel like
that's when they start really hitting
season four Simpsons yeah
batting practice just every
line can't you can't touch the amount of
jokes a Family Guy does in one episode
we're talking carto like that too though
is it I mean this is like boom boom boom
call backs cutbacks all this
Simpsons every every line too though
it's like the same I think it's the same
that's why I like Futurama a lot futur
doesn't whether it's a smart joke or or
just the most obvious joke like the joke
is just there joke joke joke joke joke
yeah yeah that's a funny dirty
Rock's good like that joke heavy like so
many jokes they don't make a lot of
those shows yeah they don't they really
don't and that show at the time was too
smart like audiences like we don't
really get it but certain people got it
same with the rest of development they
got can rest development rest of
development you have to rewatch to so
many jokes you'll miss I know yeah 30
Rock holds up beautifully though it's
really funny crazy so quick question you
guys have any peeves that you wanted to
share did youall come with any peeves
ready sure pet peeves well two je on
Christmas let's hear it uh when when you
dress up for the party but the other the
guests who arrive late don't dress
up the H we didn't get that
email I didn't get it either to be
honest it's just your
I was texted a half an hour before the
show so I clearly someone dropped out
and I'm no we
knew but um yeah you got a special out
too by the way check out uh the it's
blowing up too yeah it's doing pretty
well I'm pretty happy with it what's it
called it's called present tense but I
put on the thumbnail the Best comedian
You' never heard of as clickbait and now
people think that's the title but I
don't care and it gets haters like
you're not the best like good you're
commenting helping with the algor
you know back in the day did he did a a
a clip of himself it was the worst
comedian you've ever seen and it was
just a good set so so the comics were
like no he's actually good the best
Comics would be like I mean he's not the
worst but he's certainly not
good yeah you're going to hit a million
uh within a couple weeks I bet I hope so
hope it's great thanks guys thanks yeah
well done a toast to a a YouTube uh a
YouTube Pop I don't I'm out of boo it's
a special year everybody's got special
yeah yeah next year let oh sorry this is
me and L Wasing our beef
finally we are friends again and you had
a great opening with the it was like
Nate and uh W Cal Bell and Ali Wong yeah
yeah all these I was told not to do that
and uh uh because people want to go
right to stand up like they just want to
see stand up right away I would be
nervous to do that personally but uh
really well yeah my specials I usually
go right to the jokes I'm
nervous but it's cool that they're all
in this
cats big here in San Francisco Lou cats
was already a local Legend when I first
met him he was a young kid I can't even
tell you how
much put the work in I think Lou is
extremely funny I've known Lou for a
long time I love Lou my God he was so so
funny he's a very good joke writer he's
very funny so well written as as well
written as in front of the gohe right I
love super dirty but also super smart is
it too late to add that to
mine it's just us I
thought uh Carmen I just met her uh
she's all right I thought cuz I did one
of these I thought we were supposed to
trash you so mine's like this
jewface no you guys you guys both did it
but you did it like a promo and I needed
I needed it more like a cold open and so
I used you guys to promote it but then
it didn't work for the cold open they
just sabotaged
it oh I shot extra but yeah then they go
on they go on to roast think I said like
uh whenever people was like oh my God
it's Louis's here and I look excited and
then it's Louis cats yeah yeah it was
great you came up with that on the spot
it was great it was really good but yeah
they start roasting me in a second it's
not just prising me it's not just them
you know um it's getting too sincere
yeah but you said Eminem and it's
actually that's what I'm modeled on like
when uh I don't know if you guys
remember do you guys remember when
Eminem came out and they almost ran like
a little infomercial on MTV
where was all these like black rappers
to kind of justify that he's white like
you got to see this guy he's the best
and they ran it like right before my
name is came out and all that and I
always thought it was so cool so that's
kind of what I was great you know Dr Dre
didn't know he was white till he met him
no way fun fact yeah that's crazy that's
crazy there's there's stories like that
with Paul Wall I saw a YouTube video
where somebody say black dude was like
man I hate white people and then he and
then he's he saw Paul W on stage and he
was like oh like my favorite rapper
is white
bring him back in is he still around
yeah in Texas he has like a combover now
it's weird oh build that paw
wall well congrats man that's
awesome thanks thanks Big Year for it's
it's popping yeah yeah comedy Bubble
Baby comedy is really popular these days
oh yeah like I got in right at the right
time you should have I mean those bust
years it was crazy I feel like I'm such
an old man but like it was so different
when I started like people did not care
it was Niche underground basement no one
gave a there W there weren't
critics you know there wasn't a
dedicated person at the New York Times
reviewing it but where does it go from
here like when does it burst I don't
know it feels like we're cruising yeah I
think we we're doing all right just cuz
a podcast TV's dying you know late night
seems to be FL hate Tik Tok but it's
helped yeah it helps I don't look at it
either I think things swing back though
it's I do think like how long can
podcasts go I mean like sure I'm having
fun but like I I do think you know
everything has a course yeah people are
going to want scripted then maybe it
comes back to podcast I I think it's
going to be like a cycle I think the
podcasting that might be true but I
think and this is this is maybe a
hopeful theory that with standup it
really is truly better live you just
watch it and it's whatever you go there
you feel that tension in the room and
there's so few even music is like you
can like it or not like it but it's not
that same feeling of the tension that's
there when when you see stand up and
it's happening right then and there and
I think that's what's driving the ticket
sales is that people
looking for these experiences that can
only can only happen live you know and
you can say something kind of up
it's like it's kind of wrong and oh I
can't say that at my office I I can say
with my friends but you could say it in
a room full of people who want you to
say something kind of crazy and funny
and totally uh kind of a joke but you
know yeah and it hasn't been this wrong
in a while like I feel like HR and stuff
has gone up so like I need to hear a
release I need the other side for a
minute I got to even out yeah yeah
totally so yeah but I I agree I'm
waiting for the it feels like the bus
second are like crowd work reels going
to die down is something else going to
have died podcast will die down first I
feel like not anytime soon but in years
to come podcast will become like how we
look at AM
radio yeah but that's what I thought 10
years ago and they're stronger than ever
really yeah I keep I keep making that
excuse not to start a podcast like oh I
missed it like you know I had to be the
right at the beginning and then a new
podcast will blow up and I'll be like
well I guess CU remember reality shows
we like that'll pass and it's like
they're still here yeah totally I've
also been wrong about every prediction
like in Middle School I took a computer
class and I failed and I was like I'm
not going to need
this that was an honest thought I'm not
even trying to I was like a these hands
this is what people
need to be a
plumber although we still need them we
got all the AI up the ass you still need
a plumber you still need a roofer yeah
true all that stuff you guys see that
that what is that uh I think it was a
South Park episode I was watching the
other night where like everybody who
went to college is standing outside the
Home Depot hoping that a handyman will
will like be available the handyman are
making all the money now that's great
man brilliant still hidden that's a new
episode yeah they're like what the
did I go to college for I could have
been learning how to do stuff and fix
stuff yeah they Li always hit it how
they always hit it it's pretty crazy man
pretty brilliant it was the panda verse
the panda verse yeah yeah brilliant cuz
they do a whole thing about like you
know woke movies with Disney have to
have like a bunch of women and they're
all black and trans whatever put put a
diverse woman and make her gay yeah but
it's all about being lazy like how
that's just lazy and then he starts
bitching about woke and then you
realize oh this is lazy and so they hit
it from both sides W that's great it's
pretty pretty brilliant damn I want I
want to meet them so bad yeah oh yeah
they just seem like the coolest dudes
one of their main Riders lives here in
New York and he works at the writer room
where I where I write he's he's there
get him on Peters he's forget his name
right now he's the one that did a Wonder
showzen oh yeah yeah one of those guys
is now one of the main South Park Riders
and he's yeah he's like a I mean I'm
like I kind of like I Fanboy out when I
see him he's like not even famous but I
know he is that wond Chosen show was so
great you guys remember that have you
seen that I do it was wacky and weird
but it it was funny I yeah it's like a
hardcore like fake children show that
was on mtv2 that thing said
whitest yeah Vernon Chapman that's him
there you go
that Sam what I figured it
out I pulled the guy s getting
better hot in here yeah elf suit no joke
this is tough sweat
shop are those rented I mean yeah I mean
these are like velour I know right I
feel like stav roast in this
thing he really commits to that he wore
them on Rogan for the full 3 hour got a
uniform now yeah I guess
so damn I mean
any other peeves anyone else oh I have
um I I I'm a germaphobe and I feel like
everyone doesn't have to be a germaphobe
but like you need to respect how filthy
this town is and people don't like the
other day I saw a dude dropped his ear
pod on the floor of the train and I
figure well you're going to douse it in
sanitizer or burn it or something and he
just put it right in his ear and that is
my pet I mean just like I almost wanted
to stop are that clean though Lou I mean
come on yes I wash them every dude the
floor of the subway he should just let a
rat in his ear that's what that is
I've never seen anybody grab a Turn
Style in New York that makes me feel
really good about grabbing turn Styles
in New York I'm the only guy in the
whole city T I'm the type of dude who
would airpod I would have done that I
maybe one of these yeah but I would have
put it back in well I guess it's just
never mind it's me having problem
microphone before you got
here oh yeah or should fear wiped his
ass probably that much all right let me
hold it up there there you go
I didn't know you were that's a
germaphobe I guess so I guess I thought
it was like a normal everyone would be
like yeah it's gross and it's just me do
you get sick a lot no okay I never get
sick and I'm a Jeremy guy you what do
you like you lick the pole in the some I
rarely wash my hands uh I mean if it's
if I on them I'll wash them what if
you take a but you don't
directly on them you wash your hands
after you
damn there was a oh my
God you wipe at you don't wash your
after you don't wash your hands after
you wipe well if I get on them no
you got to wash your hands after how
many times have you had Co
four I'm more worried about pink eye at
this point never had a you've you don't
wash I'm glad we hug more often than we
shake well I do I do a fake wash when
there's other people in the bathroom he
don't even turn on the way he just
go he's like this was water
goodbye at home I I don't wipe I use the
bedet I get the
bedet you don't WIP after after that
yeah do you yeah you never know what's
all going on down there is your ass all
wet a dry oh you have a dryer mine
doesn't have a dryer it's a lowlevel b
yeah but you're just wetting the Poo no
you're blasting it off your ass it gets
blasted off blast wait you can't say
that you don't even wash your hands it's
not a civil Ros but my my asshol gets
rid of the brown you
lost lost I sound like SE when I said
that get
the get rid of the brown I'll watch my
hands after I pee just depending on the
the smell of my hands yeah I do that you
give it a sniff you gave it a sniff like
ah penis has been all right today yeah
pretty clean this is crazy this is wild
to me I wash your hands in this city
thank you the only reason I don't wash
my hands after I pee because that's how
thoroughly I wash my penis before I
leave the house there you go and then
there's pee coming out of it and now
there's I'm not touching the PE who
touches the PE you touch your
pee how do you
aim make sure it's there sniff it like a
smile arus I touch my penuts all the
time why is it just my friend's
apartment because maybe it's like an old
building or is it harder to find fart
fans in New York restrooms yeah it's
harder what wait fart f you know the
upper thing it's a it's a fan that's
sucking out the air while you're taking
a dump oh oh my God is that what it's
called yeah far that's what I call I
don't know but we but you knew that you
both knew yeah is that a southern I
guess the air my exwife I'll tell you
every restroom in Texas has two switches
the light switch and then the fan switch
dead on that way you don't stink it up
after you're done do you guys more
down there I guess so maybe we
properly more properly everything's
bigger in Texas New York you
just stuck with the smell Mark Norman
goes around farting on everybody body
everybody has to live with it that's
true there no fart fans in this city
you're right we need to get one in here
put one right above me it also helps get
the steam out when you're taking a hot
shower there you go that I mean that's
the law actually in buildings here they
have to have that in your apartment but
they don't have to have it in public
restrooms I think oh my apartment
doesn't have that really neither does
any apartment I've ever stayed in York
it's a mold thing they'll be mold if
there's not if they don't do that maybe
it's only new apartment there's windows
in there you go Windows it has to have
window or a fan that's there you go yeah
all right all right I molded my ceiling
so maybe you got something there you
really yeah a little bit I cleaned it
but it pops up gross I know I got to
wash my hands any other PE yeah I got a
peeve lines up with all these touching
poop
water wait huh what yeah like uh you
don't have home field advantage like if
you're at a hotel or something you don't
know the depth of the toilet and if
sometimes you wipe your finger hits the
water like you know at home w w what why
are you that low you wipe from front to
back I mean from Back to Front like
going under the crotch what are you a
lady reverse oh this way that's that way
then why do you touch the water I'm
saying cuz do you not lift up your butt
cheek do you go all the way behind are
you inside the bowl holy crap you go in
the bowl bow is shallow you lean this is
horrifying after that after that i' be
rinsing and washing like there so
tomorrow I'll give you a a hotel peas
when there's not enough toilet water in
there and now you're like what feels
weird now I look like an a monster what
I just did to this but it's because of
the lack of water the bowl is ruined too
much water too little water both bad you
got to stand up when you wipe I don't do
that just go like this you lean forward
though yeah a little bit stand up like
an americ maybe you have a deep ass
maybe your ass is very deep yeah you at
least got to start like lifting a
bit levitate yourself a bit don't just
go in the toilet why you what I'm saying
why you accepting that I understand the
depth of the toilet on the road I don't
this is crazy I know wet wipes wet WIP
but they they up your toilet so you
don't want to do it in your own place
cuz it'll it could you throw trash
trash I mean it's not like it's full of
poo mine
is you're first wiping and then you're
using it the uh you know what I hate
with the toilet and this happens a lot
this is weird the the seat isn't the
same size as the bowl have you noticed
this so you end up like slipping onto a
little bit of rim
you know what I'm talking about it
happens a lotd your ass is just not
regulation size it isn't dude so no I
just found this out I just found this
out I have a I have a bedet in my place
and I'm like I must have mounted wrong
cuz I always have to like lean to the
side to get it uh then I go to Japan
every toilet has a bedet it's every
toilet I my ass is off-kilter I have an
off-kilter to the side yeah I
didn't know that yeah well you know what
else could never be a
stripper what else is a problem is I
stayed in the AC Marriott you know the
AC yeah the toilet bowl is square and
the the seat is square so your ass is
like you know I got no ass a Wendy's
Burger it's no good and it was
frozen and I dropped off some chili but
it's it's square and it's your butt
doesn't fit on it right it's no good no
that's not right how do they do that I
don't know what are you doing man it's
supposed to be like an upscale Hotel a
little bit that's weird the choices they
make yeah they be nice how do you feel
about a foam seat like a cushion seat
that's weird I don't like it oh
interesting I I'm fine with it if it's
like I'm the only one using it yeah yeah
sure yes feel like someone else was on
it it feels yeah like on when you sit on
the subway and it's like the seats warm
do you like move I think it's so gross
other how layered up I am I guess I tell
you one of my pet PE and it ends up
tasting good so maybe I shouldn't talk
too much about it but I hate like
those like uh Korean
barbecue like Japanese barbecue you got
to cook yourself the food yes and then
you can't even take it to go I make
myself the food and I'm not even allowed
to take it I made the thing wait
you can't take that you can't take it to
go most places and sometimes they have
like it's all you can eat but that means
like all you can eat if you didn't eat
it they they're throwing it away in
their own place yeah yeah you can't get
to go all you can eat you can't get to
go all you can eat what am I cuz it's
all you can eat in the restaurant that's
fair yeah I don't know you're going to
put these places out of business I do
have I have a bit about having to uh
cook it myself and how much I hate cook
like I'm at the restaurant to not cook
that makes no sense crazy I don't wantes
that we're in traff traffic for an hour
stby loves that stabby was just on
here singing the Praises of does he like
to cook he likes to grill it up I think
he just likes the whole experience he
just loves Korean barbecue I love Korean
barbecue I just want them to do it for
me I don't want I don't want to do they
still and they still ask for a tip why I
made this sh I made it it's like self
checkout yeah yeah yeah give me a
cashier yeah totally this country is no
good anymore
Koreans come in we're cooking their food
for them they're like you sell it
yourself but yeah the uh that all you
can eat thing that's that's a common
thing like I went there was uh in Brazil
there was all you can eat sushi so
they'd give you like fist full of rice
with like a sliver of fish on it so you
could fill on the rice and they wouldn't
have to sell the fish so we just kept
pocketing the rice and we just left with
all this rice in our pocket so we could
get more and more fish yeah yeah yeah
exactly we had to hide it we had to like
throw out the rice my thing is though
once the food is on my table
it's not like you're going to put it
back you better not that's gross right
so let me take it to go it's already
gone it's not all you can take it's all
you can eat you got to eat it but they
fill up your plate with so much and be
like can't eat it let me take it I have
you ever gotten
high yeah never go you never got to
these places High you over you know I've
only done iasa come
on you ever done the waska no I I I'm
I'm scared I I like he's a panicking Jew
like me he's buil food I I don't even
smoke weed anymore really I
can't you get panicky yeah I get anxious
it's just like it's lit it's my joke
used to be like I used to smoke weed to
be like no worries now I smoke it's like
all worries and that's that's literally
how it is it's just like every NE that's
a part of getting old or something but
I'm the same way in the last six months
I haven't been able to smoke weed
anymore mhm yeah it's just uh just so
much it's my brain that starts talking
to me it's like horri that's why I
don't do it I start feel I start feeling
guilt yes yes totally oh guil yeah
yeah that's no good yeah I don't I don't
with I used to sleep that's my only
thing I'll take a little 5 Mig milligram
I tried to do that in uh New Orleans
once I forgot that I took it I took half
the night before I slept great all the
THC must have been the other
half cuz I wake up dude I couldn't I W I
had a dream about what panic attack yeah
yes yes I woke up into a panic attack I
had a dream about Kevin Kevin Barnett
and that he was uh dead and then he was
like you know how like you kind Kevin
Barett Kevin Barnett comedian you didn't
know Kevin Kevin was a really
funny and an awesome guy uh and he was
he was going to be a big that's Adam
Sandler you're
back that is not Kevin Barnett Garett no
Kevin was uh he was a writing partner
with Joshua benowitz who's also really
fun guy somebody yeah no I know who
you're talking about yeah he was very
funny somebody was talking to me about
him uh just yesterday he was just the
best he was so funny such a good dude
and the right amount of ball busty yes
yeah and he could backflip yeah really
just standing right there could do a
back flip dude he play the saxophone I
mean he is yeah he's crazy talented um
but I would also be sad if Kevin Garnett
died yes I'm sorry I keep interrupting
kg is great kg badass I love kg yeah
yeah and he's the right amount of ball
bu
y great Storyteller too you see him one
of these pods he's amazing
really yeah he's so funny but yeah I I
dreamed about Kevin Barnett and he was
it was
like it was like I felt like what you
know how you like most spend all your
life ignoring that you're going to
actually die I woke up like really
knowing it and then it was like I could
have my glasses on it was dark and I
felt like claustrophobic from the
blurriness and I couldn't I just I was
just flipping out man it was horrible
same to me really yeah I was with a girl
who's like take one of these it'll help
you sleep and she's like oh I didn't
know this one had THC in it and I was
like and I was like literally on a
toilet in the fetal position just like
you know by the toilet freaking the
out and she was like sorry I'm like this
is the worst night I'm I feel I feel way
better by myself I feel like way like oh
there's other little
too I thought it was just me we're a
little real men have panic attacks
too hell yeah
yeah no I hate it I don't like weed I
like to suppress my problems that's why
alcohol is a drug for me yeah although
I'm slightly interested in micro doing
shrooms but
Micro do mushrooms all the time really
yeah you can do a regular one you don't
a micro how much is a micro do like how
much do you take I don't know I've never
micro doed oh I'll be at the airport
like fullon hallucinating oh yeah yeah
the first time that I did that it
freaked me out I'm not going to lie but
I feel like I've done shroom so many
times that I could be like on like a
couple GRS just in front of people now
it's like no big deal yeah saying it
makes you jovial good mood that's my
next one I want to do that got some have
you done them before though no start off
with like a gram gram and a half but
maybe stay home or just be like on your
own with one person you really cool with
and then you'll experience like a a nice
trip there are times though remember
earlier you were saying like does it
help you figure things out there are
times where I take so much that I can't
avoid thoughts anymore MH and that kind
of sucks but there are thoughts that I
guess I need to get out the way anyway
yeah yeah it's like doing the dishes
it's like I hate it but
it for for me it's like the last couple
times I shroomed it was more like uh it
just felt good at the end when it was
over I'm like oh I got through that I
didn't flip out that's that's not an fun
experience to me you know what I mean
like oh wow thank God it's over that's
not that's oh really that's a but I
think I always like this idea you know
cuz I got into them in college it was
like let's do an E like let's let's eat
a whole you know this whole idea that
you could just eat a cap or a two caps
what like like a you gotta eat you
know the whole thing yeah and it's U
yeah so I I maybe maybe now I'll try it
with just a little bit I got actually
Hans Kim gave these me these uh shroom
chocolates at uh um at skankfest and I
have those still around so maybe I'll
maybe I'll have a little try different
ones by now what you I don't I don't
know they expire N I don't know I don't
think so I think they could I think they
could last a little while I mean
technically they're already bad they're
fun guy true yeah so mushrooms can never
go mushrooms can go bad they can go bad
that's what I'm saying like I don't
trust it after like a month or two
because I'm like what's I don't what the
is even the shelf life I feel like
they're very easily like obtainable so
just get new ones yeah you're right
you're right I have some at the
apartment if you want some thank you
I you guys take drugs from fans oh
yeah I won't take like maybe a drink but
the drug yeah it if it's package
right about the packaging yeah sometimes
I will take on that they're not offering
oh really yeah this guy brought
mushrooms to a show in Vegas and he gave
me a bar and I was I had never tried a
candy bar yet at that point like a
mushroom candy bar he's like yeah man
it's really good he's like I've been
micro do in on mine throughout the day
and he was like a little less than
halfway done with his bar like a third
of it done and I was like give me that
one too he was like nah M my bar I was
like nah give it to me I like you don't
know what this is do
you I I shake Dam yeah I lost a fan that
day
but I don't know what he thought I
was what a weird imagine meeting one of
your favorite comedians and they're like
I'm just going to I'm going to steal
from you yeah I still I I'm bro I'm like
I probably have a little bit of a
problem I'll steal drugs from my friends
like I I'll steal mushrooms and I'll get
mad if they take mine oh all right yeah
it my show give a penny take a penny
yeah somebody brought mushrooms for for
me and my my two comedian buddies Louis
and jus and they gave me a bar we each
had a bar and then they brought an extra
bar like a bigger one and they were like
hey could you get this to hisus when you
see him and I was like yeah yeah yeah
like yoink that's mine now like you seen
that have you seen that bar they left I
was like
nope damn my now does he know about
it or this I was going to find out N I
told him about it later I was like look
man they did bring it I was like but
I'll buy it from you he's like nah you
can just have it I don't want to get
into arguments with you and I'm not
going to be like no no no you should
take it your I was just like okay said I
could have it is mine there you go you L
me of
chocolate it it wasn't I did but I did
skankfest this year and then I did a s
Santa Cruz Festival I ate so much weed
after these two I don't even smoke it
it's like and I'm just traveling around
with it and you know it's it's cool if
you're going to the right States
afterwards but you could be going to the
wrong State and it's like well what what
am I supposed to do with all the
now you know true your moon tower gave
us something too and I took it and I had
to change my flight oh wow it was too
much yeah
b sometimes people like it's only
happened like twice but people try to
give me Coke and I'm just like do I
really look like I do
Coke you seen
my to risky to do Coke these days I
think so well that's I mean I my uh I
had my batch party this year in Costa
Rica where it's legal and that was
awesome really because it's legal it's
closer so it's not cut with anything man
like Coke is maybe the best drug maybe
the best
drug
there's no come down we could go to
sleep without a problem when it's pure
dude we we do as much then just crash
out when we had to crash out you don't
even have to do that much cuz you get so
high up just a little bit so good I
can't do it n because of I know I just
don't like I just don't like drugs that
make me want to don't talk him into
doing coke I'm just look my point is
that it's so rare to about Coke was
wrong like I would I wouldn't do it here
because of the fentanyl thing I just
won't I'm so scared of that
but if like the pure cocaine is like
amazing feeling is so like have you have
you ever done done I've tried it you
tried it and it it just like woke me up
it felt like a breath of fresh air and I
don't want that I think it's I think
that might have been a little methy yeah
yeah because it makes you feel like it's
where you realize like why they call it
getting high you literally feel like
like you're like just floating and it's
so good man you feel so good I mean like
like the opposite of a guidance
counselor trust me this is it when
it's
pure but are you doing the cliche
like we got to start a bar man and we
got to write a movie and we're going to
go to the moon and we're best friends
forever no well also the other thing is
for me I I'm really sensitive to um
uppers so I just did like one line and
I'm good I'm like good for a while I
don't even there's not even that cuz
sometimes you Coke here like you do it
like all night like I think I feel it
and like this is like I'm good I feel
great you know that's for me I don't
have a I'm not really like give know but
man it was it was incredible a lot of my
lot of people I know like to do Coke
when they're out drinking so that they
can just keep drinking and then they'll
do Coke so them up and they'll be
drinking till like 10:00 in the in the
morning I don't like to be up when the
sun comes out no me neither and also
like your body's telling you to stop
drinking it's like it's trying to shut
you down you're like shut up you know
yeah good point yeah performance
enhancing drugs for a bad
performance it's like you're trying to
get up all night it's that's bad
for you yes yeah yeah yeah totally
totally damn well we should do some
Costa Rican blow yeah it I mean Costa
Rica only in Costa Rica that's I really
really did you know a guy or like how do
you call I know but like you can't
dispensary how do we know was clean
because why would there's no reason to
cut it with first of all everything's
cleaner when it's closer to the place so
it's the distance from a location where
who brought you the Coke in Costa Rica
just some guy like yeah my mom made this
like a mom po nice Tri
fed yeah maybe don't say who gave it to
you but was it like a I don't know no
it's like there's a there's like it was
my Bacher party so there's like a guy
who like can arrange everything for the
B the sad part was he was like a pimp
kind of too and no one got a hooker and
he was so that we made the pimp sad he's
like I've never seen this he was like he
was depressed was like no one like
really like no one like not only cuz he
missed money but he like didn't even
understand he couldn't fathom I'm with
him couldn't get a hooker I me yed up it
was it was I think it was hooker
self-esteem I know it was too big of a
group and people there's too much like
stigma I think you if you want to get a
hooker you want no one to know that you
got a hooker and it was like everyone
would have known that you got the hooker
and then if everyone was doing it but it
was too big of a group for like everyone
to do it so it kind of messed things up
be great if it was just one guy and a
group of like 17 yeah
yeah yeah true man I don't think there's
anything wrong with getting a hooker
know now you know I have money and I
just got laid yes Pro sex work yeah
totally so this cocaine this is melan's
bachelor party I
assume all right where are you guys
going to be at what do we got ones and
by the way three killer specials here um
on Mark Norman's YouTube on on your own
YouTube Lou Catz and Ralph Barbosa
sorry I was going to say my tour dates
are on my website Barbosa comedy.com
we're doing a theater tour we're going
to New York town hall theater I think
that's a
beauty uh San Diego
Chicago um a bunch of cities Nashville
Wilbur nice Boston yeah doing Boston I
can't read that far so Theater in
Chicago on February 2nd good room
February 3rd also the BC theater
Buckhead after that Atlanta Los Angeles
Netflix is a joke Festival in may see
you there February 17th in Tampa Florida
Tampa that's a fun comedy Town Tampa I
was just there I love Tampa great crowd
what do you got I got a I'm in a Tampa
was great January I'm in a well is this
when does this come out January
Christmas Christmas I was in Austin last
week and I sold
out so you missed that but uh in January
I will be at the uh punch line in
Sacramento I am I'm doing a night at the
Irvine Improv and then I'm at um in
Colorado Springs at Looney in February
so come check me there also Charlotte
North Carolina 26th of January that's
with the tell he can sell his own
tickets and how you guys doing on New
material cuz you guys just put out
specials this is a tough time I've been
doing it for a while ever since I I
taped it I was like banking banking yeah
yeah mine is uh because it took me so
long to edit it I'm fine I taped it I
taped it may 2022 and it just came out
so I waited a year and a half to put it
out so yeah since that time I've it's
not ready to tape but I it's it's all
different jokes yeah great yeah all
right what about Carmen there let's my
dates aren't I have I seriously need an
agent I've been booking myself my agent
is gone so he got
F so I have a few dates up there I'm at
the Kennedy Center I'm at Syracuse this
weekend I'm in San Diego hell yeah um
but yeah more is coming go to her
website and watch her special on YouTube
yeah and also it's like you said there's
three special but technically four right
cuz you have two specials coming out
right one on Friday that's
awesome oh yeah all right I'm at Mark
Norman comedy.com check out my I
met also in Tampa and Jacksonville and
Columbus and Indianapolis New York at
the Beacon second show added Lexington
Charlotte San Anton Houston go to Markov
comedy.com get some Bodega cat
and uh what you got uh Blue Room
Springfield Missouri I'm back in clubs
for a minute just to tighten the special
which I'll be taping in March at the
Wilbur AES very pumped for that one but
yeah we got Blue Room in Springfield uh
Madison comedy and state only really
good clubs coming up Philly punch line I
can't see uh you got Oklahoma City yeah
you got Irvine Stanford Connecticut look
like Omaha Salt Lake City Wise Guys and
then the big taping March 7th and Irvine
as well I think we missed awesome all
right J Mo that that'll be all I think
they're all sold out already so that's
going to be great oh that's huge a hot
show you want to plug anything you got a
new kid I got a kid but some mom's
taking some time off but I'll be back in
January with shows all right there you
go buy yourself a bottle of D cat
whiskey
yeah on sale online we're still looking
for a distributor if you know anybody bu
whiskey buy a Corvette yeah combine the
two a you're tough
just like to dedicate the show to Kenny
to Forest who
pass yeah honestly really tough uh great
guy hilarious guy and uh we've known him
a long time and and we heard the news uh
very recently that uh things were not
looking well from what I gather he was
it was a hidden run and uh brain damage
terrible yeah so funny guy look up his
stuff really funny and a good person and
a very sweet person you know I believe
uh my friend James Webb directed one of
his specials uh our friend who directed
both of our specials that right and uh
Chicago Pro yeah Kenny uh real Chicago
guy a Hoops fan a great guy uh ran
comedy at the Knitting Factory uhal B
withes and will and we we just found
that out right before the taping today
so uh and there is a GoFundMe I guess
for his family this is uh this is pre-
taped so yeah this is late but uh cuz
you know we W not be in town for for
Christmas but yeah he'll be missed he'll
be missed and uh you know to Kenny you
know very very tough and happy holidays
weird note to end on
sorry we're going to do some Costa Rican
Cod cowabanga thank you if if we find
about if we could maybe put the GoFundMe
in the link or oh there you go all right
well thank you guys thanks for listening
Merry Christmas thank you for uh happy
Hanukkah happy Hanukkah as well it's
Christmas today though and uh you know
uh thanks for spending another year with
us we love you guys and uh this was a
great app so thank you all for coming in
Kito
[Music]
coito a little
too and's talking fuing and I get
down in the same
way up on the roof like a cop coming and
naked Samuel is feeling
dangerous I'm out to lunch here in New
Orleans this woman doesn't look like I
remember and I get down in
the
we
be
true